Welcome back!
My voice is still kind of...
Clickbait thumbnail.
I said I'm sorry for false advertisement.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Also I feel like Chibi Minto's head is too big for this game.
It takes up too much space.
She lied.
Where is Lilac?
It's me!
It's who you want to hang out with, right?
It's Mid Phantom.
Everybody cheer!
Squeaky Minto my oshi.
Now my voice is still kind of warped.
But that's okay.
Why do they sound so tortured?
No!
They sound wonderful!
Today, I want to beat Eternal Darkness.
I don't know how much time I have left...
In the game.
Sorry, not...
This sounds so ominous.
Guys, I don't know how much time I have left.
My favorite streamer made Mint Paragon.
Are you going to die again?
I'm going to die again.
I'm actually so sleepy today.
I'm sleepy always.
Goodness gracious.
I don't know how much time I have left in the game.
But I want to beat it today.
That's why I'm starting a little bit earlier than my usual streaming times.
Hopefully we beat the game.
I really hope so.
Let's start.
No, go back.
Load game.
You got this.
Hopefully.
Let's hope.
Streaming at a somewhat EU inclusive time.
No 7 point Paragon?
I made this last time.
I didn't have time to make... Oh my goodness.
I have a baby crying.
I didn't have time to make another Paragon.
I'm sorry.
Alright, so I believe we just got...
Yes, the next chapter page.
I hope Lilac hates us.
She's so base for that.
I think Lilac hates you the most, King Arthur.
Thank you for 5 months.
Thank you.
Alright, let's get into it guys.
Let's get into it.
A Legacy of Darkness.
1952.
Oh, hold on.
Let me move the...
I'll move this right there.
I don't think that's related.
Maximilian.
It's like really depressing though.
Look at that.
We are pretty bizarre, yeah.
Secrets.
Oh my god.
We are grandpa.
Is this grandpa?
Are we going to figure out how to use that dang telescope?
Let's grab...what is that?
A journal of family history rests on the mantle as if used recently.
Take our historical journal.
That is thick.
Oh my god.
Liquid Courage!
A small flask of the old sauce.
Liquid Courage.
A magical elixir to power one's spirit in the face of adversity.
Bottoms up!
This regains our sanity.
This is saucy Liquid Courage.
Yeah, I guess Nintendo is just like, no, no.
No drinking.
No abuse of the bottle.
An old musty book bound by dry, dusty leather.
This book covers the early history of the Roivas family.
Dating back before the settlers in this land.
There appears to be something pressed between the pages.
Should Edward get it out?
Yes.
We have a minute hand of a clock!
What is that?
What was that doing in there?
Hold on, I want to talk to you.
Maid.
Maid, I wish to speak politely.
She asks Edward if there is anything she can do for him.
Yes, maid.
Sometimes it's so funny when I get, because of the way, you know, I'm Mint Phantom, but because of the way I put like maid mint and stuff on Twitter and YouTube and everything.
When I get like spam, like business emails being like, we want to work with you with this tool or whatever, they call me maid.
They're like, dear maid.
No Edward, you don't have a mythical family history.
It's called a family history of mental illness.
So true.
These books contain the history of the Roivus family, genealogy, birth and death records, deeds and writs.
What's a writ?
The Roivus history is a troubled one.
As Mediterranean immigrants, the early Roivus were shunned by other settlers in North America.
What?
Suspected of witchcraft?
The Roivus were convicted during the witch huts, forcing them into hiding.
As memories faded, the Roivus rebuilt their lives.
What's this way?
There's a storm ahoot.
A thick layer of grime on the window prevents Edward from looking out into the garden.
That's gross.
Clean your window, Edward.
Despite the efforts of the servants Edward hires, the mansion continues to sink into decay.
Oh my god, that lady scared me up there.
Maid Mintfantom.
Oh, we have the hand!
I thought your last name was Ch.
Yeah, Channel, yeah.
First name Maid.
Middle, Mintfantom.
Last name Channel.
A large carriage clock, sitting in the foyer table.
Beautifully crafted, but it appears to be stuck, with the hand set permanently to 3.33.
Oh, okay.
3?
Oh, I guess it would make sense.
How would it be 33 if it didn't have a minute hand?
Yeah, why not 4.44?
So true.
I'm Maid.
Portraits of the ancestral rooibos line the foyer walls.
Wait.
Their faces reveal a dark, brooding edge.
There is something about each one that gives the viewer an unsettling feeling.
I'm feeling unsettled, I am the...
Oh my god.
Ma'am?
You're scaring me.
As Edward nears, the servant stops mumbling to herself and asks him if he thinks the weather will clear up before the solstice.
Edward finds the reference to the solstice rather odd and ponders its significance.
This may be the end of eternal darkness, but you will never escape from eternal dorkness!
So rude, Blake!
How could you?
Got some revolver ammunition.
Can I go in here?
With no one living in the house for a long time, it's no wonder the pantry is empty.
Edward lives out of the refrigerator, so to speak.
Oh gosh, another guy.
Scares me.
I wish to speak.
The servant notices Edward's presence and comments on the weather.
Idle chit-chat.
Can I open the fridge?
Can I get a little midnight snack?
No?
Alright.
Let's go in here.
This room freaks me out.
Ever since we saw that guy hanging.
Edward has never learned the piano, but that has not stopped him from hammering away at the keys now and again.
It is very therapeutic.
Perhaps one day, he would learn it properly.
I don't think so, Edward.
I'll take that!
An antique cavalry saber.
Mounted on a display stand.
Gleams in the moonlight.
I'll take that.
Does this super color look like mint to you?
Clove?
Yeah!
It's a little...
It could be a little lighter.
It's pretty... It's almost mint.
It's like so close.
You look just like my hair, for real.
There's a permanently immiscible powerful gun in this level that requires a bit of forward planning.
Rett!
You're back!
Alright, let's get that powerful weapon, baby!
Looks too turquoise.
That's what I'm saying.
It could be like a little bit more...
You know, it's a little dark for mint.
Maybe.
Puttering around with the crockery, the servant informs Edward that the table has been set for him just as he likes it.
Time to eat, baby!
Wait, can I actually sit down?
No!
Let me eat!
The sigils.
I can't see anything.
It's too dark.
Turn on the lights, grandpa.
Let's see.
We have this clock, this minute hand.
It doesn't go to that clock.
Is this to the basement?
Oh my gosh, why didn't they keep these doors?
Cryosight!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I'm colorblind so I'll take your word for it.
Thank you for the Akasawa, thank you!
Thank you so much.
Oh my gosh.
You're not colorblind, are you really?
Wait, why can't we hear the...Oh my gosh.
Why can't we hear the rain anymore?
It's my birthday!
Happy Superview!
Kuro, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, Kuro-Nassa!
An exorbitant and out of place stained glass window ends the hallway.
Whoever put it here had eclectic taste and confirms Edward's belief that the mansion is more folly than a real house.
How do we...
Ma'am, did you hear that?
Where'd you go?
Where did the maid go?
Oh, here.
Did you hear that?
Excuse me?
She informs Edward that she believes the weather will worsen.
That she hasn't heard it being this bad for many decades.
We have to find, maybe...
The book?
What a strange angle.
Oh my god, there's a lady.
Muttering to herself as she works, the servant comments on how the mansion is never really clean.
Whispering
Gosh, I felt that too.
More shotgun shells.
Oh wait, a shotgun?
Edward is reassured at the sight of the family gun cabinet.
Itself a priceless antique.
He would rather not have to smash the window to get inside.
But where did he leave the key?
You've been extra squeaky lately.
I know.
It's not good.
My voice is not doing so hot lately.
I don't know why.
The Journal of Family History rested on the bench.
We got a historical journal.
What's inside this one?
An old, messy book bound in dry, dusty leather.
This book covers the recent...
Wait, what was the other one then?
The old history and the recent history.
Recent history of the Roivas family.
Going back perhaps a hundred and fifty years.
There appears to be something pressed between the pages.
Yes!
We got an hour hand!
My hand, your hand, our hand.
Elephant gun.
Is that the gun you're talking about?
Wait, is that the weapon?
The elephant gun?
This isn't that.
This is the shotty, right?
That's not the elephant gun, is it?
It's a big gun?
That sounds intense.
Oh, okay, my bad.
I was trying to talk to this guy.
Courteously, the servant asks if Edward is in good health.
Aww, thank you.
I hope you too.
Okay, bye.
Alright, let's see.
If I were an elephant gun...
More ammunition?
More ammunition.
I can't get into any of these.
Oh, it's this weird painting.
Brooding, melancholic paintings adorn the walls.
Strange choices of decoration for a bedroom.
Each one seethes with a virulence that could only have been wrought by an unsound mind.
So...
Have you seen my elephant gun?
No way virulent mention.
Courteously, the servant asks if Edward is in...
Oh, okay.
You are the exact same.
I can't even see it.
If you were an elephant gun, you'd be in the trunk.
My bathtub.
The master bathroom is woefully spartan and only barely contemporary.
This guy complains about everything.
Hi, hi virulent.
Have you tried PayPal?
Oh yes, I do use that, the syrup.
I do, I do.
I haven't had any today, but I've been drinking it in my tea.
Maybe I should just do it by the spoonful, usually that helps my throat heal faster than drinking it.
The master bathroom is woefully spartan and only barely contemporary.
It appears to satisfy the most practical of tastes, or perhaps someone who has their mind set on other things.
What does that mean?
What does that...
It's made out of elephants?
Don't say that.
I mean what, we're in the 50s, right?
They didn't really care back then about...
Our elephant gun has to be in here.
He shot with the elephant gun.
Maybe.
Where haven't I been?
I haven't been to...
Okay, so we have these...
We have the minute hand, oh sorry.
We have the minute hand and the hour hand.
The hour hand.
Where is a clock?
Besides the one down here.
Oh my god, Bigfoot, Bigfoot servant, oh my gosh.
Can I use it now?
No.
That truly was like a Bigfoot pose.
Isn't the...
The really cool room, isn't it behind here?
Or am I not remembering correctly?
I thought there was another door.
I just needed to come here the whole time.
Oh my god!
The other, the cool Rooibos.
The cooler Rooibos.
Maximilian, yeah!
Yeah!
This guy looks like...
He looks just like me.
He is so awesome, he is still here.
Let's go back.
Oh, there is the clock.
Okay!
Wow, what a puzzle.
What's this?
Magic pool?
What is that?
Magic pool, eh?
Now how do we, okay.
Solve this puzzle.
How are we supposed to know what time to set it to?
It's not empty, there is plenty of stuff in here.
With an almost patriarchal air of it's own.
The ghost asked Edward to set the clock, but there are no hands on it.
Edward must find the clock hands so he can set it properly.
Way...
Way ahead of you.
Have you found the summon ghost spell yet?
The runes are Mado, Minto, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin, Bustin.
Alright.
Detail.
Should Edward...I want to adjust the clock.
I want to do it.
Oh okay.
3...33?
About right there.
About...
Oh!
About right there.
Bustin, Bustin, Far Gone, Bustin, Far Gone, Bustin.
Secret room.
That was like close.
That was like 3.34.
He is so shook.
He is like...
Let's grab some weapons.
Let's grab this weapon.
The loaded revolver.
I'll take that.
Though I would like a torch.
Elephant gun ammunition.
How do I get the elephant gun?
Shotgun shells.
Shot...oh a revolver.
If I were a key...
I feel like I looked everywhere though that I could've...
For now is what I mean.
When game gives you this much ammo it only means good things.
I want a melee weapon.
Oh wait, I do have a melee weapon.
I'm an idiot.
I picked it up.
I picked up my melee weapon.
Practice.
Good practice.
Nice.
Alright.
I do want the elephant gun though, so if I get too far...
And I don't get it, let me know.
Minto, I was told that my Kamiyoshi goth mid-lilac would be streaming today.
Have you seen her?
Hope you are doing well.
You know, how goths can be...
You know, she was supposed to stream today and then she was like...
She was like...
This is actually kind of pointless.
And just left me to take care of it, so...
You know.
Alright, here we go.
A strange... It's funny getting the Tome of Darkness.
Sorry, the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Not in the screaming room, you know.
A strange leather-bound tome sits closed amidst a pile of books and papers.
Should Edward pick up the tome?
Yes.
Tome of Eternal Darkness!
So many things...
Oh...
I think you'll figure it out.
If you're at risk of missing it, I'll drop a hint.
Thanks Red!
What does the pool spell do?
This dread scroll contains the secrets of an arcane magic.
It reads...
This magic transfers the innate magical energy of the environment to the self.
The limitless power of the ancients...
Sorry guys.
Oh my gosh, I don't know why I can't stop yawning.
The limitless power of the ancients will be at your disposal for the duration of the magic.
Once the magic has waned, you will be bereft of spiritual power until it naturally seeps back into your being.
So I...
Okay.
I bet all the people in the mansion are going to turn on me now, aren't they?
They're all going to start attacking me, aren't they?
No!
My maids!
Alright, so we gotta find a key and we gotta find...
We gotta go behind that door.
No!
My maid is getting...
The dog ran away!
What is that?
No!
God, she's hot!
I'm sorry...
Oh my gosh, she's punching me.
Sorry maid.
Can I finish you or...
Wait, what just happened?
Oh ok, my bad.
Oh, she's gone now.
The dog ran away!
What did we get?
We got...
Half a key tumbles out from the vase that has been toppled and smashed.
It glints on the floor.
Bottom half of the basement key.
Do I have to break all the vases to get more keys?
I guess I have to kill every single maid.
That scared me.
I have to kill all the maids here.
There can only be one.
And that's me.
Ok, the music is like really freaky though.
He was green.
Wait, did I not...
Ok, enchant item.
I'm just gonna enchant.
He was green so we do red.
Does that make her green?
Yeah, we must eliminate the competition.
So true.
Maybe I'll just make it purple.
On my sword.
Ok, let's go.
Everybody possessed now?
Oh my god!
Do something!
Maybe I can do something.
Oh, where is he?
Where are you?
Master bedroom.
Ok.
Was it this one?
Hey, move!
Move or something!
I'll save you!
Oh, I saved him.
I think I saved him.
He is...
What is...
He is sucking more power.
Are you ok?
Shaken by his brush with death, the servant gives his thanks.
He warns that the creature might still be around.
An extra firepower would be handy.
Reminded by his own words...
He fishes a key from his pocket and gives it to Edward!
I forgot he got attacked first.
I need to save that guy for the key.
I got it!
Yeah!
I don't even need your hint, but thank you.
Alrighty!
Extra firepower for real.
Let's go get it.
I thought I was gonna have to...
What?
Oh, I forgot when I use this, it growls.
I was like... The face is growling at me.
Serval, it's your birthday!
And Putin!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday Serval Gwen!
Happy birthday!
I think I'm in this maid's way.
Is it this one?
Yes.
No guy here.
Excuse me.
Oh, let's get the key out.
The gun cabinet is now unlocked.
Pick up the elephant.
This function allows the character to change the fire, but...
Wait, fire selector.
What does that mean?
Mode?
Oh, what?
Wow!
Interesting.
Interesting, OK.
How many?
I only have 24 bullets.
We have so many shotgun shells.
Where do I get the shotgun at?
I can fire one or both barrels.
That's crazy!
OK.
Oh, excuse me.
Thank you.
Alright, we got what we needed.
My Oshie is packing, always.
Let's see.
I have this gun.
And I have half a key.
I guess let's just explore.
Save?
Oh my god, I just heard something.
I don't think I can save.
Let's...Damn it!
I don't think I can save here!
The monster is on a timer.
You can follow it, then kill it after he starts attacking a servant to get more ammunition.
You can reveal invisible.
You can track it.
No way.
What is that?
We know where he is!
OK.
Right here.
I can save you.
I can save you!
My sword is done, so let's just equip this thing and...
Oh my god!
I can't even...OK.
Oh my gosh.
That was some crazy recoil.
Wait, but my health...
Wait a second, I can heal again.
That's right.
I have the book.
Are you OK?
Grateful for having their lives spared from the monster, the servant offers a token of thanks.
Elephant gun ammunition!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm gonna do a big spell.
He has low, low health.
Oh my goodness.
He has very low health.
OK, so cast...so he is...so...oh my gosh.
You guys, I ask this every time.
I'm so sorry.
I cannot remember which spells...
So if I am doing the reveal invisible...
Would it be green or would it be red?
I can't...Pokemon rules, but it's not always Pokemon rules.
Someone keeps leaving my AOL chat room.
I know, right?
Oh yeah, now I can save.
Thank you.
Oh, with that hideous creature running around and attacking servants it's probably not a good idea to save right now.
I have to kill it first.
I've watched this game four times and still can't remember.
There is like one thing...
that makes it so...there is like one spell that I do the same instead of opposite.
So that's why it always confuses me.
OK, um...Pokemon rules for all except shield.
Oh!
OK, cast...do I need it super powerful?
Do you think he is a really powerful guy?
Can I just do like a 5 point?
Maybe I should do a 7 point.
That's the exact time you would want to save as a player.
I know, right?
This is so mean.
It has to be 7 point.
OK, so red.
Alright, let's go find this ugly...Oh my god, she scared me.
You are not the ugly.
Hey, guy?
Where are you at, guy?
In here?
Where are you at?
Ugly?
Ugly.
Oh wait, there is nobody in here.
What does that mean?
Oh my god.
No!
Come here!
Oh god, I'm gonna switch to the gun again.
Actually, what if I equip this gun instead?
Oh my god.
Bro.
Oh, not the lady.
Not the lady.
Not the maids!
Oh my god.
Stay away!
Where is it?
Oh my god!
I'm sorry, maid!
I'm sorry!
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no.
I'm gonna die.
Let's see...
Friendly fire.
I can't use heal magic because he is still chasing me.
You guys, I have to stand still.
He's gonna hit me.
That's how it works.
If you don't let him attack the servants first, they don't know they've been saved and won't give you spare ammo.
What?
Oh my god, this game is ridiculous, I swear.
I swear.
Ok, hold on.
Attack the maid!
I'm leaving.
Maybe I can heal in here.
Well, I don't think I need it so much.
And let's reload.
Nice.
Ok, and let's go back up.
Oh my god.
I'm also going to...
He's green.
What do I want to do?
I think I'm wasting bullets here, so let's do this.
He is camping!
Cool spell with purple rune is very helpful.
Awesome, thank you guys.
Ok, let's...
I guess we'll kill him or attack.
She looks scared though, right?
In its desperation to escape from Edward, the vampire creature drops the top half of a key onto the floor.
Oh, we got the top half!
Let's go.
And he's gonna...
...absorb some more goop.
I love that he actually comes from the basement door.
That's so funny.
Are you ok?
Wow, she really doesn't know that she got saved by me.
You suck.
Give me more ammunition, please.
And I...now...
Broke it.
Oh, we've assembled it.
Kind of.
She was literally cowering.
How do you not...
Oh, I still can't save.
No way.
If I die, I'm gonna have to do all of this all over again.
It's cruel.
It's actually cruel.
You did shoot her.
Okay, just don't die.
Yeah, just don't die.
I don't think I've saved since, like, a while even.
So, let's see.
I have this.
It's broken.
Yeah, it does appear to be broken.
So now we...
Do we...
Do you remember how to repair objects?
Yeah...
Yeah, obviously.
That which is broken shall be fixed.
I have to enchant it.
Cast...
Which...I just don't know what power level.
I'll do purple.
Unheal.
It's just a key.
Yeah!
There we go.
And someone mentioned having my shield up.
You know what?
That is a really good idea.
Since my...
My health is so low.
So let's do...Okay, shield is the same, so I need green shield.
Okay, now we need my thing to go back up.
She's like, why are you glowing?
Alright, let's go to the basement, I guess.
Even though I wish I could save and this game is so rude and mean to me.
Oh boy, what do I hear?
Oh my god!
I don't know if I'm hitting it or not.
No way.
He's gonna do it in front of my face?
Oh my god, leave.
And shield.
Cast...do I even have enough for shield?
Cast...shield.
Yes!
Alright, round two!
Hello?
Oh my goodness.
No!
Oh my god!
Stop this!
My...what is it called?
My enchantment disappeared, so...
But the shield is working.
Yeah, it's working alright.
No!
We gotta run around.
Cast regen magic.
Use my magic to cast to get more magic.
Please cast magic pool.
Okay.
Purple pool.
Do I do it now or do I do it when he's here?
Just in case.
Just in case he walks out the door, you know.
Do it now, it's a lasting spell.
Okay.
I couldn't really tell what it meant, you know, so...
Alright, time to magic pool.
Oh wait!
We need tear and red gormor.
Tear.
Red gormor.
And I'll make it like this as well.
What was it?
Tear.
Red gormor.
Alright.
Cast purple.
I have...whatever that means.
I don't.
So, if I go back down...
Yeah, he's still here.
I'm leaving.
Now you'll regen.
What are you...
Oh, I do!
No way.
Oh my god.
I'm regening for real.
But I need...
I'm gonna enchant...
On my sword.
Actually...
Yeah, on my sword.
Okay, awesome.
And then...
Let me shield a little bit.
Gosh.
I don't trust his health against this thing.
Bangalore Park.
Sand Cell Park.
Alright, now I'm ready.
Come here.
Where are you?
Don't you dare.
Don't you dare!
Go get his butt!
Don't...get him while he's eating!
Get him while he's eating!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
Ouchie, ouchie.
Break free!
Do something with this so that he can stop using it.
The simple obelisk made from an alien stone sits atop a wall.
A runic design is carved onto the side proclaiming its allegiance.
Okay.
Where are you?
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I'm gonna die.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait.
Please.
Please no!
Oh gosh.
I need to get out of here.
Please hurry.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh my gosh.
Destroy the stone.
I know.
Maybe with the guy...
Oh my gosh.
I mean I'm still regenerating which is good.
It's just I wasn't regenerating fast enough.
Scary, scary, scary, scary.
Magic pool saves the day.
For real though, I would have died.
I would have died, died.
Alright.
So if I enchant...
You know what?
It's time for the big guns.
Actually, I don't want to waste it.
Let me through.
Wait!
I destroyed it!
Oh my gosh.
Please.
Ok.
I destroyed it.
So let's leave.
And now...Hold on.
Ok.
Now I'm gonna...
Sorry guys.
Ok.
Now, I feel like it's best with my thing.
I can get the most hits because I missed too much with the revolver.
Paragon, Minto, Paragon, Matara, Paragon.
I cast a spell to get some calorie mate.
Damn, this lasts...this pool lasts a long time.
Oh, just kidding.
What is the time?
Ok.
It was red.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it disappeared literally in that moment.
This is so messed up.
Alright, cast shield and then I think we'll be ready.
Paragon, Sand, Paragon, Paragon, Paragon.
Oh my gosh.
Alright.
Here I go.
Get his ass.
Get his ass, Rivas.
I'm trying to get his head but...
What was that screaming?
Yeah!
Save the game!
Ok, I feel so much better now.
I feel so much better now everybody.
A new spell.
Summon horror?
I hardly even know her.
What does this one do?
It's the big guy, yeah!
I think we get to summon him.
More...what's this?
What's this?
Oh the shotgun!
We got a double shotgun.
Why is it so small?
Shotgun shells and some more ammunition.
Oh no.
Inside the well, a crumbling ladder leads down into the cloying darkness.
Should Edward venture down the ladder?
Not yet.
Wow, they are really stocking us up you guys.
Oh my god.
We have a lot of ammo now.
53, 84, 54.
It's not really...
I'm scared.
Yeah, that's not indicative of anything.
I don't think there is anything else to explore in this so...
I guess we must venture down the ladder.
Which we've seen before.
As...
As Rooibos.
Maximilian Rooibos.
Here we go.
Oh my gosh, it's the JPEG city.
Maximilian had not lied.
The city is miraculous.
It glows in the darkness like an incredible jewel.
But the thought of what lies inside, the guardians of Zealototh, make Edward shiver with fear.
Nine great towers dwarf the surrounding city.
Perhaps the towers serve as a focus, channeling great tides of energy into the city itself.
Flat city.
It's like artifacting and everything.
Okay, here we go.
With my sword.
He looks so confident going down the stairs.
That doesn't sound good.
Is it that dog again?
Oh, it's a big guy.
Two big guys.
They don't notice me, do they?
Oh, I think they do.
Maybe we can lure one big guy at a time.
Okay, so...
Maybe two.
Summon your own big guy.
Should I?
Can I?
Alright.
Big guy war!
If I summon him...
I can't do purple.
A red guy.
Wait.
Yeah, a red guy.
That's so messed up!
This game!
Wait, I'm stuck.
Okay, there we go.
Nevermind.
What?
Why even give me the spell right before?
Why?
Why even give me the spell right before I come down here?
That's messed up!
Oh, I need more space.
Like here.
Oh my god, that was so close to hitting me.
Oh, here we go.
Here he comes.
It's my big guy versus your big guy.
After a horror has been summoned, press A to attack enemies.
Attacks can be targeted using R.
So it's the same as aiming.
Attack an enemy's head from far away to perform a shock attack.
Press...
What is that?
Start?
To release control of the horror.
Horrors can open doors, but not... They can open doors?
Okay, here we go.
Ouchie ouch.
Wait.
Okay, turn around.
Okay, my guy is kind of getting bodied right now and he also can't walk properly.
Wait!
I'm aiming and attacking, but it's not working.
Wait, why can't he walk properly?
What the...
Why isn't it working?
Oh my god, they're way bigger than me.
They're way bigger than me.
Time to summon another guy.
How much do I have?
Time to drink up.
Wait, no, this is for sanity, isn't it?
That's for sanity.
Staff member has died.
No!
Here's one to restore your streaming power.
Oh my gosh, how many angles is that?
Take the super chatter advice.
Wait, what was that?
Superior enchanted shot from both barrels of the elephant gun to the head should one shot any enemy in the game.
It also pierces enemies.
That's not useful.
99% of the time.
Okay, so let's enchant.
You know what this game feels like?
It feels almost like...
The way you have to do the spells and everything...
The amount of time I've spent in the menu, it feels almost like a...
Like a...
Like a turn based RPG.
You know?
Oh my god, I hate running down here.
Okay, hold on, I gotta escape for a second.
Shoot.
Can I do it on the stairs?
Yeah, probably.
I can do the shortcuts.
It's just, you know...
Alright, let's go try.
Oh, reload.
Oh, how do I reload this?
It doesn't let me.
Mix?
Like that?
What the hell?
That's so strange.
That's so weird.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, that was close.
Get up!
You gotta be fast!
I can't tell...
I think I got him.
Take the shot.
I got him!
I'm gonna finish him with my sword.
Finish him.
Whack!
Whack-a-doodle!
Yippee!
As Maximillian had mentioned, the ruins of the ancient city of Edengar were parasitized by the Guardians.
They had slaughtered the original inhabitants and fed upon them, laying waste to their civilization.
You need to hold aim for a few seconds to steady the elephant gun before firing, or it knocks you on your butt.
Oh, that's why.
The ghosts of glorious past lie forgotten, and the chitterings of the parasites echo amongst the remnants of their legacy.
That's crazy.
I'm scared to go anywhere.
Not that way.
We're so small.
Okay.
Anything over here?
Nothing?
Okay.
Let him breathe a little bit.
I didn't know you could keep it from happening.
How long do I have to keep it held, I wonder?
I guess we just go inside.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Wait.
Before I do that...
Yes.
Yes, baby, yes.
Let's...
You need to let it hold for about long enough.
Ain't that just the way.
Should I do health or should I do all?
Are these spells just what I gave for Elder Gods?
Yes.
Purple is best for this spell.
Okay.
I know I probably should enchant something that I own currently at the moment, but...
Oh, boy.
Oh, no.
Oh, God.
Okay, equip.
I think I got the shot.
Oh, I need to reload.
Oh, my God.
They're really... Please reload.
No.
No, turn around, please.
Oh, my gosh.
The controls in this area are really hell.
They're really hellish.
They're really hellish in this area.
Please, reload faster.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
They're... Oh, my God.
They're really hell.
Damn it.
They're getting up on me.
I'm gonna die here.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, my gosh.
Edward has perished at the hands of the eternal darkness.
Okay.
It's alright.
We just saved.
They did out park on me.
I was trying to shoot, but maybe I do have to use my guy.
Maybe I should summon...
We shall summon a giant guy.
This one.
Yes.
Okay, here we go.
The green horror zap attack is what's scrambling your controls.
Oh, really?
Okay.
So it's not just like a...
A weird thing that's going on with the map.
It's actually...
If I send him in there...
Pre...
What if I send my guy in there, like, before him?
You know?
What if I just let him go in?
Alright.
Maybe...
Here.
Alright.
Off I go!
Good luck guy!
You got this!
Good luck!
Oh my gosh.
Move, move, move, move.
No, no, no.
He's really scrambling my controls.
Oh my gosh.
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Take him down.
Oh my gosh.
What the hell is that?
Oh.
What is this?
One guy down!
No!
Ouchie.
It's okay.
Keep going.
Keep going!
I don't know if I'm doing anything.
Oh he's summoning things.
Ouchie, ouch.
Come on!
I think I'm hitting him.
Wait, he's got a shield?
Maybe.
I can't tell if I'm doing anything.
I'll be honest.
Am I doing anything?
He's got a barrier.
Come on guy!
I don't think he's getting through the shield.
I don't think it's working.
Alright, we'll just let him die I guess.
You're doing good!
Dispel.
Can I do magic from here?
Enemy barriers cannot be destroyed by combat.
I think he's still alive in there.
Save scumming.
What if I send another guy in there?
There he is!
Oh no.
Okay, we have to use the dispel.
I know we have to use the dispel magic.
Are they fighting?
Alright, maybe from like...
Ouchie, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Do you think he's going to notice me or...
They'll fight for sure.
Maybe from here it will work.
Alright, here we go.
Wait...
Dispel is Pokemon rules?
Pokemon rules, right?
That didn't work.
We have to time it when they're doing their...
When they're doing their thing.
Guys,
am I going to beat this today?
Guys, am I going to beat this game today?
I really want to.
I want to start other series, you guys.
As much as I'm having fun with this game...
It's been a long time since I've been playing it.
Alright, let's first enchant ourselves.
Not enchant item.
Give us a little bit of a shield, baby.
Nevermind.
Give us a little bit of a...
Let's go for a brisk jog.
Because we're going to need enough for the dispel.
Am I going to have to kill both of them?
OK, so we need...
I'm going to do the magic pool.
I'm going to do...
I'm going to do the shield.
And then we just need enough for the dispel.
And we'll be good, I think.
You'll need a red shield to keep your health.
I can't believe I accidentally...
I tried to let him die.
I really did.
This is the last big difficulty bump, if I remember right.
Oh, really?
If not, it's OK.
We can persevere.
We'll persevere, everybody.
This level and the final level are quite long.
There's one chapter in between that's not as long.
OK, cool.
Should we be good for the shield?
Oh, wait.
OK, OK.
We're good, good, good.
Hopefully...
We can...
I'm going to do... Actually, I'm going to do my health.
I'm going to do my health.
Master.
Master!
It's a secret ending in the first chapter if you let Pius die.
Really?
Go to the options in the main menu and listen to music.
I'm playing right now, but maybe I'll do it later.
Let's see.
And then, magic pool.
And we'll do purple.
I don't want my shield to go to waste.
Wait, the shield doesn't disappear unless it gets...
It lasts a while.
OK, let's see.
OK.
Alright.
Maybe now.
Nice.
OK.
Oh my god, just barely.
I...
I'm regening magic, but...
OK, we gotta do the dispel.
We gotta do the dispel.
The dispel magic.
So I need to run around just a little bit more.
Just a tiny bit more.
OK, OK, OK.
Just a little bit, a little bit, a little bit, a little bit, a little bit, a little bit.
We gotta have enough.
So I can go in and run and do it.
Sign into a hotkey.
Yeah, I guess I could, but it doesn't waste time.
Eh, magical attack.
I have recover.
Or Y.
Recover, recover, magical attack.
Let's see.
Let's do dispel.
We'll do the dispel one at the top.
Dispel magic.
Assign.
It was a 5 point.
So I can do 5 point and then...
Oh, red.
There we go.
OK.
Hokey, tokey.
Ikky, my show.
I can't believe he's there.
No, you are my guy.
You are supposed to be on my side.
Messed up, so messed up.
OK, go in.
OK, good, good, good.
Alright, now...
I think I was too late.
It disappeared!
You think...
I'm going to...
Summon a guy.
I'm gonna summon a guy.
I'm gonna summon one.
I'm gonna summon a horror.
And I'm gonna have him kick their butts.
He's just standing there.
That's my guy!
Here we go.
Oh, he's dead.
Nice.
We're acting like it's a...
Kaiju battle.
Are you kidding me?
Are you kidding me right now?
Wait.
Wait, are you kidding?
Are you kidding me right now?
What's going on?
Oh!
Oh my god!
So we are getting him now and he's getting scared of us.
I think I am... It won't let me throw the Ultra Ball.
It won't let me throw a long range attack and I'm not quite sure why.
Oh my gosh.
Where did he go?
What is happening?
Oh, he's right here.
Again?
My guy is just standing there.
Okay, it doesn't help that we are so slow.
We are so slow.
Oh my god!
Stupid!
Just stay here please.
Where are you going?
Stupid fairy!
She was a fairy.
Oh my god, please.
My guy is literally just chilling.
Oh
my god, please.
Okay, that gave up.
Whatever that was.
Why won't it die?
I don't know.
Oh my god, I thought I finally got it.
He's gonna kill my guy.
Am I doing this right?
I don't even feel like I'm doing this correctly.
Okay, now we wait.
Oh, nevermind.
Just kidding.
Where do you hide behind a shield?
Oh my god.
No!
I am hitting him.
But...
I'm definitely hitting him.
No!
Now we are faster I guess.
Okay, hold on.
I don't know if I'll make this.
Did it just put up its shield again?
I think I just saw it put up its shield again.
You little bitch.
Maybe that's why I wasn't hitting it.
I can't stand this guy.
So I was hitting him.
I was doing the right thing.
It's just... I don't know what's... I don't know.
I actually don't know anything.
I'm actually so confused.
Oh yeah, I keep getting knocked on my butt.
Reload.
This thing is so stupid.
But...
I didn't get...
Was that it?
What
are you talking about?
No!
So he just had a bajillion strength.
Oh my gosh.
Or health I mean.
Yeah, we did it baby!
Okay, all these things...
I don't know if I dispel the magic and go through them.
But let's just walk around for a bit.
That was just a test of my patience.
More than anything.
Good job.
Here we go.
These plinths look like the ones Pius had encountered in the Forbidden City.
Where he found the essence of the ancients.
Edward briefly wonders what their purpose could be.
Are we going in that?
Okay.
Oh.
A pulsating field of energy emanates from the stone should Edward touch the field.
Yes.
Oh my god.
We are portaling somewhere?
Where are we going?
It's a stargate?
Yeah, for real?
What am I hearing?
Oh no.
These guys.
Oh, these guys.
I think I killed him.
Yeah.
Wait, maybe I should have taken that.
Wait, can I get out of here?
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
What's going on?
What is this?
Chill out!
Your sanity is not even that low.
These spires appear to be focusing magical energy from a nearby source.
Perhaps if a rune is marked on the spire, it will affect the flow of magic.
Could the spires themselves serve as a circle of power?
So what's the rune?
I don't see it.
Oh!
Can I change it still?
Oh, I can.
If I feel like it.
If I feel like it, I can still change it.
Oh, what?
Guys...
What one did I pick at the beginning of the game?
What one did I pick at the beginning?
Was it green?
Did I pick sanity at the beginning?
So I need red.
If it's like a power thing that's going to overwrite like the...
Yeah, yeah.
Since all the things here are green...
We want red.
Okay, okay.
I get it.
I picked Bulbasauria.
Oh no!
Oh my gosh.
Time to summon a guy.
I love summoning horrors beyond my imagination.
Oh my god.
His eyes light up.
It's so scary.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Oh my god, my enemy.
Hey, go away.
Go away.
Seriously.
Just leave.
What the?
Wait, what just happened?
What just happened?
No way.
Oh my god.
And he disappeared.
Wait, I think I should die.
I think I should just die.
I saved.
I saved after I did that fight.
My sanity got too low.
Just kill me.
Because
I'm not gonna fight both of these guys.
It's fine.
I saved.
I can't believe he just... As soon as I summoned him, he was just like...
I'm not controlled by you.
Summon monsters reduce sanity.
If you run out, they disengage.
So that's the downside of summoning the horrors.
Okay, I get it.
I understand.
I got it.
I think the big guy did do a lot of damage though.
But also, I don't know when he put up his shield.
That's okay.
We'll just... Alright.
We can just...
Do this part again.
It wasn't that bad.
Yes.
Alright.
I'll save before I go into the next room though.
Let's grab that.
And reload.
Six shots.
Morning Mito!
Good morning!
Alright.
I look like a zombie here.
Spooks me.
Freaks me out a little bit.
Alright.
Let's subscribe.
Like and subscribe.
Now before we go in...
Mix...
Wait.
What do you mean?
What do you mean I can't mix?
What do you mean I can't mix with the...
Edward cannot load a weapon that is not equipped.
Oh.
I need to learn how to read.
That's what I need to do.
Mix.
Alright.
Let's enchant it.
It must have taken a ton of sanity then.
Because...
I mean my sanity is low, but it's not like crazy, crazy low.
And let's magic pool.
And let's go in with my fists baby.
Let's go in with my fists.
I almost forgot to like.
Thanks for reminding me.
Thanks for liking it.
Appreciate it.
Make sure to join Chiturgu's membership.
Oh!
I forgot to save!
Guys, I'm an idiot.
I'm so sorry.
Can you go a little faster, you know?
Nice.
Reload.
Oh my god.
Just two hits?
Wait, for this guy even two?
That's insane.
Nevermind.
Holy shoot.
Yeah!
Take him down!
Oh my god.
Now I can save.
I'm understanding the power.
Summoning was doing nothing in your favor.
Okay!
Well, at least I try.
At least I experiment.
Let me experiment in the game.
Let me try things.
I like feeling safe inside my magic scribe bubble...
and then letting other creatures do the work for me.
Is that so bad?
A lever?
Oh my gosh.
Pull the lever, Edward.
Okay.
I guess it worked.
I guess we are good.
Wait, which one opened?
The one in the very back?
The one I was looking at before?
Have this at the ready?
Oh, we have to keep going back?
I understand.
Just in case.
So we are going to go to each little pillar and we are going to make it red...
and then my thing is lagging.
My sim... what are those called?
The things above the sims.
It's lagging.
I'm running too fast.
Edward is a speed demon.
Okay, so now we go to this one.
So they are all going to be red?
A plumbob.
Is there anything here?
Nothing?
Paragon!
Come on.
Why can't you stay enchanted for longer?
Just in case.
Nothing beats a good old paragon.
We are paragoning in the city, you guys.
I never would have thunk...
I never would have thunk we would paragon here.
So exciting.
Sorry, I don't mean to save scum, but I'm nervous.
What is that?
Matara!
Alright, let's pull the lever.
Wait a second, I see some runes.
What's in here?
Nothing?
Hack on the wall.
Get your very own Matara statue.
Oh no.
Wait, what's happening?
Matara?
Oh my god.
The worms.
The worms are inside us.
The worms are taking over.
This looks suspicious right there, right?
Wait a second.
Did that use one of my drinks?
Seven.
Did that use some of my liquid courage?
Can you imagine if it did?
That would be so messed up.
He was so fast too.
He was so fast with it.
He was like, I know what to do.
Wait, what?
Oh, just kidding.
I'm running into the thing.
Excuse me.
There we go.
Let's go with this one.
Have you guys seen that guy that's like... I don't know.
He's like some streamer.
But he's like so good at...
I should probably... My thing is enchanted.
He's so good at exiting a game when there's a jump scare or something.
He just literally will be like...
And he's out of the game.
Like he'll just quit.
I saw him like... I saw the clip compilation of him on Twitter.
It was just like he's playing Resident Evil 7 and something happens.
And you barely even see the jump scare.
He's just already out of the game.
It's so funny.
Yeah, he's some flesh tuber.
I don't know who he is though.
I like that these guys are one hit though.
Why am I so small?
Do you think I'll hit it?
Nice.
There's one more.
Alright, reload.
Reload.
Re-load.
Reload the gun.
Reload...
I keep forgetting I have my shotgun too.
Built to Minto scale.
It's not even an Alt 4 macro.
He's really pressing every key to leave.
Yeah, like it's crazy, right?
It's so funny to watch.
There we go.
OK.
Pull the lever.
Are we going to get wormed again?
Oh, a worm is going to come out of that ceiling.
Run away!
Don't get wormed.
Alright, we're good.
Oh, I have to go a long way.
Just kidding.
Beat tuber.
Reload now.
I did.
Are you proud of me?
Strike Warlock, are you proud of me?
All I need is your validation.
Good work, Beat tuber.
Thank you.
Wait, this one is so cool.
It looks like there is an eye staring down...
and like the little tentacles and stuff.
It's so cool!
Beat tuber, why?
Wait, where are we?
Oh, OK.
We got to go up.
Wait.
Where are we?
This way.
Are you OK, man?
He's so tired.
OK, interesting.
Alright.
Let's keep going.
It's just pulling a bunch of levers.
That's easy peasy, right?
Would you still love me if I was an eldritch worm?
Yeah, I think so.
Now would you love me if I was an eldritch worm?
You'd probably be like, oh yeah, baby.
Do you guys love anything new and different?
If I'm purple, you love me more.
You guys are too used to me now.
You're just like...
She's old and boring.
I need an eldritch worm now.
I need her to be purple.
I need her to be purple now.
Or else I'm not interested.
It's OK, I'll be new in like a couple days.
And by a couple I mean like...
By a couple more like...
20 days.
22 days.
23?
Days?
Days.
Pargon!
There we go.
Alright.
We keep on pargoning.
Old and boring?
Mintz, you are not boring.
Are you sure?
Wait a second.
You forgot a part of that sentence though.
The spam is going to be real confused if you changed your last name to Lilac.
Made!
Lilac made!
Glory be to Mintorok.
Did I save?
Whatever.
It's OK.
I've been saving so much this whole time.
I've been saving so much this whole time I'm like not even concerned.
If I die I won't even go back that far.
That far.
Oh, just kidding.
Alright, here we go.
I must also...
I must also enchant.
Let's do our gun.
Pargon!
And since I have a lot of magic I will...
Just go back to the magic pool.
I like how this one is whispery.
That was so close you guys.
Where is he?
Wait, does he have a shield up?
Does he have a shield up?
Oh, yes he does.
I didn't even get to reload.
Dispel magic!
Red.
Thank you for the red!
I can't see who's name it is.
But, thank you so much!
I'm reloading very slowly, but surely.
Nice.
Reloading.
Where did he go?
Pargon.
I think we got him.
Very good.
Alright, good job everybody.
Good job.
I love...
I love the thingy!
Thanks for the gifted!
Sorry guys.
Sorry, I was in mid-battle.
Thank you for the red!
Thank you so much!
Oh my gosh!
Murphy, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Raymac, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Hello everybody!
Welcome!
My name is Mint Phantom.
I'm a Ghoulish-made Vtuber.
I'm playing... I'm actually on the last part of this game called Eternal Darkness.
It's an old, old game from Gamecube.
Casey, thanks for the gifted!
Ducky, did I say thank you for the gifted?
Thank you so much!
And it's a lot of...
It's a lot of...
Pargon and spells and crazy stuff.
And watch, I'm gonna kill some guy.
Wait, where is he?
Okay, I know he killed one guy because he like literally zapped him.
Did he kill both of them?
I think... I don't have to do literally any work.
Yippee!
Driver says thank you for the gifted!
Nochan, thank you for the gifted!
That's so much Pargon.
There's our... There's our lever.
Can you imagine if there was just bullets down here?
The game wouldn't be so kind though, would it?
Surely it's not that old.
When did this game come out anyway?
Pull the lever.
2002.
Guys, I think that's old.
I think someone born in 2002 can now drink.
Mickey, thanks for the gifted!
Frozen frog, welcome to Mambo Ship.
Thank you.
Is this the door that just unlocked?
I think so.
Oh my god, spooky.
Spooky eye.
Alright, so we went through that one.
Okay, slowly but surely we're getting all these done, baby!
Let's go back to our room.
So right now we're pulling levers.
Okay, so see how everything is green?
The opposite of green.
Wait, not opposite.
Green's nemesis is red.
Just like Pokemon.
So we are setting the city on fire.
Kind of, actually.
We're actually kind of...
Yeah, we are setting the city on fire, aren't we?
Why is it not a perfect star though?
So we have one, two, three left?
Three.
Oh, four.
My bad.
Four left.
Let's get these two over here.
Nice.
Yeah, because everything is evil.
It's been taken over by...
Oh, we have to stop the eternal darkness.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that spooked me.
Get out of my way!
That's right.
Okay.
Examine.
Wait.
This sure seems like a Paragon civilization.
Oh no.
We've just been given Paragons.
And I don't even have this rune because I missed it.
I don't know what it does.
Let's finish this.
Us 02 babies are 22, Minto.
I'm a month older than this game.
Little baby.
Think.
What do you want to do to the city?
Also, I'm off to work now.
No!
Good luck with work.
We want to...
Do we want to absorb the city?
We want to protect the city?
But we are trying to get the things out of the city, right?
So like...
Thank you.
All things begin with Paragon and also ends with Paragon.
You are no different, Mint.
Wait.
In the end, all things must return to Paragon.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Spell list.
We are trying to get rid of the guys out of here.
Right?
So...
Nethlick and Redgore more.
It must be the one that is the question mark then, right?
Maybe.
Oh, off work.
Not off to work.
You scared me.
Oh my gosh, you scared me.
We are trying to dispel the green guys from the city.
So, Nethlick is going to be the literal only one that we don't know.
Right?
Yeah.
So this one.
Question mark, question mark.
You.
OK.
Sometimes I read fast because I'm like I gotta get back into the game.
I gotta get...I'm gaving you guys.
I gotta get back into the game.
God dang it.
Oh, I didn't even...
Guys, I didn't even reload.
I like just...
Oh my gosh, and there is little thingies here.
Spell list, enchant cast...
On you.
OK, and now...
I gotta get rid of these.
Oh gosh, I can't even see where they are.
Nope.
Oh my gosh.
They are just chirping all over my ear.
They are chirping all over...
No, no, no.
Not blue.
No.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
Wait.
Stop, stop, stop.
Red.
Go to red, please.
Red!
Oh, maybe red was a bad idea.
Yeah.
I can get more health.
Alright, let's head out.
Just kidding, we are going to purple.
OK, good, that purple.
Yeah, not any other purple.
This purple is good.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Is that a dead guy?
Wait a second.
There is a guy there.
Oh my gosh, please.
No, no, no.
Oh my god, please.
OK, thank you.
Wait, who are you?
Wait, wait!
What was that?
OK, I hear more.
I wish I could see.
Oh my gosh.
I can't see anything.
Of course, of course, of course, of course.
You ass.
Anything you...
Summon trappers, teleport, end up in the dimension next time you are there, including enemies.
So I could just have it full of guys, huh?
Spell.
Dispel magic.
Red.
My turn.
Anon Rivoli!
Welcome to...Numbership, thank you!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that's not enchanted anymore.
Of course not.
Time to enchant?
This is so much.
Holy moly.
Alright, where did he go?
Where did he go?
Did you...Did he put up another...Oh my gosh, he put up another one.
You jerk.
Dispel magic!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, he's still not dead.
Is he going to put up another spell?
Or...
Got him.
We got him.
I think he healed in between.
And that's what...
I think that's what got me good.
Okay!
I gotta stop doing that though, because I don't have so many elephant bullets, you know.
I think we are good.
Let's...
Get this guy.
Oh, the lever.
Yeah, I have magical powers.
I'm so awesome.
I'm so cool, like I'm just a guy who can summon things and do whatever, you know.
Alright, let's go.
One, two more.
Okay.
I'm screwed for...What?
What do you mean the elephant fight?
I have 23 left.
We're okay.
I have other guns too.
We're fine.
The elephant fight.
Where I have to fight the elephant.
We're going to be so...Guys, the elephant.
We have no more elephant bullets to kill the elephant.
Oh, let's do this one right here.
The elephant takes 24.
Oh no!
There's 24 elephants!
Okay, I don't hear anything.
Far gone!
My favorite.
The city...
Looks like it's starting to clear up a little bit maybe.
Getting rid of all those guys.
Oh, it's still enchanted.
For how long though?
Wait, how do I get over there?
I don't like this.
Wait, I don't like this at all.
I know you guys are going to tell me to not summon a monster, but...
What if I summoned a monster?
Do it!
What if I summoned a horror and had them fight?
I like the Kaiju battles!
Then he would have to die and then I would dispel the other magic.
I want them to fight.
Fine!
I'll do it myself!
Oh, I need a gun that can...
Oh no!
The enchantment went away!
What if I do the double shotgun here?
Here he comes!
Oh my gosh.
Get his head.
Get his face.
Get his face!
What if I got everything but his face?
Oh my gosh.
Ouch!
Did I get him?
See guys?
It was so easy.
RIP the big boy.
He had to go.
I'm sorry.
Oh there is a spider up there now.
Alright now.
Not damage.
Enchant...
We'll wait on this.
Because I don't want it to disappear.
We need to get rid of those things.
So I need my tiny gun.
My revolver.
Oh come on!
I could have been so Revolver Ocelot there.
I think I killed it.
Alright!
Let's see.
Who just took a ton of my sanity?
Who just took a ton?
He really parg on him.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
I'm right up on top.
I'm gonna take a step back.
There we go.
Oh yeah, dispel.
Didn't I set this to something and I'm just not using it because I'm an idiot?
Sorry guys.
I think I definitely set this to something and I just completely forgot about it.
I'm just more comfortable going into the menu.
I'll be honest.
Oh, did it dis...
Did he reinstate it?
Chuu!
I took your sanity.
Sorry.
Do you want it back?
No!
I'm good.
Thanks Ashes.
I'm gonna cast it just in case.
I think it's healing.
Enchant.
Maybe I should have enchanted this earlier.
Maybe I'm dumb.
Who knows.
Oh my god.
Take him down.
Finish him!
Cinematic!
Did you just put up another shield?
Nice.
OK.
Reload.
Make up your mind!
Please!
Got him.
I'm so curious what the sanity effects are here.
Sorry that I'm not letting my sanity get super low, but his... Edward's health is so small I'm scared of him dying.
You know?
Kablam!
Absolutely.
We're a blessing.
Otherwise I'm really curious what kind of crazy stuff you could see or happens in here.
We could tell your real life sanity is low instead.
Absolutely.
It's not safe.
The darkness is coming.
Why isn't it safe?
That was strange.
Safe's coming real.
But...
This...
This way.
Over here.
We pulled the lever there and it opened up here.
I remember.
Alrighty, we still have two more.
OK.
How is our health and everything looking?
Our sanity is alright.
Everything is good.
Everything is alright.
We're OK.
We're alright.
Reload the elephant gun.
Yeah.
Let's do that.
Why can't you be like Metal Gear and reload yourself when I unequip you?
Why can't you be like... Why can't more games be like Metal Gear?
Why can't every game be just Metal Gear?
This section is a little too long.
It's long, but it's not so bad now that we got the hang of it a little bit more, you know?
I don't feel...
After this part, how much longer is there though?
I wonder.
I guess we'll see.
Any creatures?
No creatures.
Oh my gosh!
Who could have guessed?
Far God!
I really like these views though.
They're really awesome.
I think I hear a guy.
Nevermind.
That's suspicious.
That's weird.
Oh?
That's suspicious alright.
I guess we'll pull the lever and see what happens.
What the heck is... What are these?
Here stands the remnants of a forgotten museum.
Perhaps long ago, the alcoves now sealed with clouded glass would have been filled with the creatures and artifacts of lost Enga.
I don't like that.
That one in the corner looks too wet.
Right?
He looks like he's going to come alive at any second.
I like it.
Oh my God, he's like glistening.
These guys are going to come alive.
Him too!
Right?
Oh my God.
He looks too wet.
What is that thing?
I'm scared.
OK, time to pull the lever and wait for our ambush.
I didn't even notice he was in there.
He's so small.
I didn't even...
Petition to rename drinking streams to liquid courage streams.
Absolutely.
He was so tiny, I didn't even know he was there.
Oh, it's so cute.
Oh wait, oh yeah.
Equip.
Mix.
Oh, my bad.
Oh shoot.
Ah, no, don't examine!
Oh my God.
Ah, please!
No!
I ran right into it.
Do you think Pius Augustus could get presidential paragon?
Oh my God.
Oh look, this is actually pretty safe.
We can get some sanity back.
Let's go to green.
Green.
Go right.
Green now.
Green.
Turn.
Turn to green.
Green.
Red.
Turn now!
Go to green!
Moe moe kyun!
Turn green!
Moe moe...
Kyun!
Oh my gosh.
There is a guy here.
Hello.
Don't mind me.
Your head?
Hello?
Are you gonna drop down now?
I took you out.
Finish him.
There we go.
That was so fast.
Alright.
To purple.
That's what everyone said to Mint Phantom.
They were like, purple!
Purple!
To purple!
Go to purple!
I just replenished that.
Don't do this to me.
Ok?
I just replenished that.
Don't be like this.
There is another guy.
Oh my god, you are not dead?
Oh my gosh, I just replenished it.
You jerk!
Lilac Paragon.
I'm so curious about that guy over there though.
Like that's another human.
Hug the wall.
Can I examine?
A young man's body lies hunched against the wall of the platform.
Blood from the viscous wounds surrounding his face and neck soaks the remnants of what appears to be a uniform with a sickly dark red.
You think he's fine?
You think he's ok?
Now... ok.
Let's equip this.
Let's mix this.
Let's... even if I have to shoot the small guy with the shotgun, I will.
Let's enchant it.
Oh, that one guy was red though.
Should be fine.
I can't use spells in the trapper dimension.
Oh, just kidding.
Alright, let's go back I guess.
You're getting got!
Dummy!
Oh my gosh.
Reload!
Finish him?
Sorry, I'm wasting bullets.
I'm wasting bullets, but...
Reload.
Hurry up, hurry up, please.
Alright.
Come here guy.
I wish I could see anything.
I can't believe I still have a shield.
That's kind of incredible.
There he is, ok.
Alright, this makes things a little bit easier.
Little bit...
Oh, dang it.
My shield!
Reload, please.
Reload.
There we go.
Alright.
Headshot?
This guy is not going down, is he?
Oh my god, my controls.
It gets me every time.
Please, please, please, please.
Oh my goodness.
Finally.
Finally, finally.
And finish him.
Give him a good old whack.
Ok.
Nice, nice, nice.
So once a trapper takes you to the trapper dimension, you...then...
You...it dies?
I guess?
They die.
Interesting.
I never realized.
Maybe because I just always one-shot them.
With my gun.
Alright.
Let's leave.
And do this one...one...or two more, I think.
Or is there one more?
Can't remember.
Let's go.
Two more.
Two more, two more, two more.
Oh, I'm stuck.
I thought I heard...I thought I heard a trapper.
This one is...Who would have guessed Bargon?
Who would have guessed?
Wait, so if we did this as Grandpa...
Why is the darkness still coming?
Why are we still in trouble?
Grandpa messed up.
Oh, Grandpa messed up.
Grandpa, Grandpa, we're in trouble, Grandpa.
Grandpa, we're in trouble.
Does the enchantment...
Also equate to the power?
Or is it just how long it stays enchanted?
I don't know if we're gonna make this.
That was so close.
Nice.
Length only.
I did not mean to enchant that.
But...I did not mean to use my elephant gun.
But here we are.
The girls are fighting.
Wait, I'm just gonna...
May the best girl win.
Yeah!
Kaiju fight!
Oh, that was over very quickly.
Ok.
Oh shoot.
I'm strapped in here.
Run, run, run, run.
Ok, good job, good job.
Good job, Matthew!
Cheers!
Ohayo!
What do we win?
We win the opportunity to pull the lever.
Lucky us.
We are the lever pullers.
Ok.
Ok, ok, ok.
I'm exhaling over myself.
Are we ok on health and everything?
This might be silly, but I'm gonna pull myself.
There we go.
Alrighty.
Oh, that's where we came from.
But there's only just one left, right?
Blah, blah, blah.
Alright, just the one right over here.
Okidoki.
Is this it?
Is this the last one?
So I probably have to choose the correct thing.
I don't quite remember.
We'll have to check the spell book.
Yeah, ok.
Let's check the spell book for dispel.
Check.
It was Nethlic, which was the one we didn't know.
And Red Gormor.
We know Red Gormor.
Red Gormor.
Scribe!
What's gonna happen?
Oh, we can leave!
Edward's meddling with the arrays has conjured incredible energies that are now building up inside the city and can't be contained for long.
Edward needs to escape the city.
Run, Edward!
Edward, get out of here.
Edward, it's time to leave.
Oh boy.
Something's rumbling and it's not my tummy.
Oh my god.
Do I just leave him?
I think.
Just run.
Wait, what's that?
Oh my gosh.
Oh, dang it.
Oopsie.
We need a purple.
Purple.
Minto.
Purple!
We need to get out of here.
Is that a guy in there?
What if I just ignored him?
Oh, he's like a tiny skelly.
Get out.
Go.
Get.
You're embarrassing yourself.
You're ugly.
Ugly.
How do I get out of here?
I think this way.
Oh wait, where's the door?
Where's the door?
This way.
I found it.
Oh my gosh, it's really rumbling.
This way?
Oh, it's rumbling.
OK.
Run.
Is that sound?
Oh no, no, no.
I think I can just leave.
Oh my gosh.
Let's just leave.
Let's just get out of here.
Can I...
I can save.
But I should leave, probably.
I should probably go.
Oh my gosh.
It feels like my sanity is low, but it's not actually.
OK.
Go.
Run!
Grandpa!
Go up those stairs, grandpa!
Oh my god.
Wait, what about my house?
Am I going to be OK?
Oh, cutscene.
Oh my god.
This is a dream come true.
Let's go, grandpa.
Let's go.
Part gone.
48 years later.
That's me.
Oh, that's my grandpa.
That's not me.
We didn't dispel everything.
No.
Of course not, because why else would we be doing all of this?
Ventrel!
Welcome to my workshop.
Thank you.
That's how they got my grandpa.
It was that thing.
Chapter complete.
Gosh, that took me a long time.
Yippee!
Only one?
Treachery?
What?
He's like...I don't know what you're talking about.
I want to team up with Augustus.
Wow.
Once again?
When were they here before?
Tome.
Grandpa, no.
Only one tome chapter in MC side.
She's like totally fine for a person who just discovered how their grandpa died.
A small note written on a page from the Tome of Eternal Darkness.
Dear Alex, I have left you a small surprise to keep you going when everything seems to go awry.
It was my favorite...tipple?
And there are several burials of it in the basement.
Please help yourself to what you can find.
My guess is that I won't be needing it.
Your loving grandfather, Edward.
What is a tipple?
Sorry, I forgot our sanity is so low.
So we're going to the basement?
Oh, grandpa's booze!
Let's go.
I forgot last time since I left before you ended, but Alexandra can get a shot on the wall in the basement.
I missed it before.
Oh, no way, really?
Well, since we're going back to the basement, let's go.
I noticed my sanity is doing something weird in the corner.
I'm not sure what.
It's like flickering.
I don't know why.
Yeah, who needs sanity?
Yeah, I should save, shouldn't I?
Thank you for reminding me.
Oh, Edward.
We've gone through...we've been through three rooibuses now.
It's kind of fun.
It's exciting.
Oh, I don't like this one.
Oh, it sounds like really...
Oh, my God.
Where is the...is it...we still haven't figured out this thing.
Is it in the safe?
Oh, we need the stethoscope.
Oh, the walls are bleeding again.
We did this with the coin.
The music starts.
Oh, hello.
I will take that.
Thank you.
Got the shotgun.
Is this grandpa's magic?
No.
Did he put it...wait, examine.
Oh, there's something stashed between the barrels of port.
Should Alice pull it out?
Yes.
A pickaxe?
Minecraft?
I'm playing Minecraft now.
Oh, I cannot use it.
Where do I...
Is there anything in here?
Oh, yes.
Doesn't quite seem to be for this.
I am Steve.
Let's see.
What can we knock down?
Is it this?
It wouldn't be this.
These are just barrels.
And it wouldn't be this.
No.
What other things were boarded up?
I think the ladies crying are just gonna get on my nerves at this point.
So I'm going to heal myself.
I'm just annoyed at this point.
Okay.
Alright, so finally some peace and quiet.
What was boarded up?
What was...
Oh, that room upstairs?
I thought we would need an axe.
Like an actual axe for that.
Not a pickaxe.
Let's see.
Let's see if it works.
On this room, right?
Can I use it here?
No way!
Why are we using a pickaxe?
That's...
Doesn't seem like the appropriate...
I don't know.
Alex is so hot, isn't she?
Her and like Laura Croft look like they get along together.
Maximum...
What are you doing?
Oh my God!
Grandpa's grandpa!
What are you doing?
He killed all of them.
Oh!
Oh, woah, woah.
Woah, what's going on?
Dispel?
Is it a 7?
Grandpa's just a little paranoid.
Oh, that didn't do anything.
I'm afraid of... Okay, hold on.
Wait, examine.
Ouch!
Sorry, I was thinking...
I'm an idiot.
Sorry, it's blue.
Try blue.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Sorry.
I'm too green brained right now, you know?
Everything is green.
Red, green.
Oh my God, no wonder they boarded up this room.
There's blood everywhere.
Scary!
Oh my gosh.
If you remember his chapter, some of the staff were secret bone thieves.
Yeah, I do remember.
So that's why he went to the asylum.
That's so sad.
Examine.
Should Alex retrieve it?
Yes.
Oh wow, that's an old boy.
And then we get another thing.
Should Alex retrieve the piece of paper?
Yes.
It was actually only a tier 3 barrier.
Oh, which is fitting because that's all Max had access to.
Fair.
It's hard to tell.
It's a fight.
We get our magic back so easily.
Journal of M.
Roivas.
Closing notes.
This is a page from Maximilian Roivas' journal.
It reads, As I contemplated these ideas, my suspicions of my servants grew and I became increasingly fearful of them.
I began to watch them carefully.
Days ago, I watched one of them stretch his neck.
I could have sworn I saw it twist in a most peculiar direction.
And a bulge of muscle tissue collect and grow in the most incorrect of manners.
As if a bone was being displaced from its proper location and something else moving in its place.
I stumbled away, knowing that I was surrounded by unholy creatures that wore the skins of mortal men and women.
I had to take action.
Dear God, let my hand be swift and merciful, lest the world see more of these diabolic creatures.
I like how her hair looks like a cute doggy's face when she is looking down while facing the camera.
Alex?
I can't get her to look down.
Oh my god, it does look like a dog!
I see it.
I see the eyes and the big nose.
Oh my god, it looks like a dog!
She's got that dog in her.
No!
No, this is our sanity, right?
No way.
No way!
Oh my god!
Yeah, this is our sanity.
This is our sanity!
We're going crazy!
Oh my god!
This is our sanity!
Bone, bone, bone, bone!
I'm dying?
Wait...
Oh my god.
I'm pushing up!
This is our sanity, right?
Oh, ok.
Oh my god, there are so many creatures.
Oh my god!
It's not our sanity?
Alex is in the realm.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Alex is...
Oh my god, no, no, no.
My safety!
You were never sane to begin with.
No!
What's my health looking like?
Ok, we really need to get more sanity though.
Oh, dang it.
I pressed the wrong button.
For the little creatures, for the little guys we'll...
Dutch angle no more!
For the little guys we'll use the gun.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
No, Alex, you're not supposed to be here!
You're not supposed to be here!
Yeah, kill him.
And kill the next one.
What do you think was keeping all the monsters at bay all this time?
And you got rid of it.
The barrier?
Oh no.
It's gone.
It was just one.
For now.
It was just one for now.
Oh shoot.
Alright, we gotta make it to the basement.
We gotta make it there alive.
Nice call.
Why do you look so fabulous standing there?
Actually, maybe I will use the shotgun.
It has 7 rounds in it.
Can you guys stay down please?
Just go.
Just run.
Just go Alex!
Just go!
You don't need to attack all of them.
Just go to the basement.
Are you OK?
We're fine.
We're OK.
Probably.
Everything is fine.
Everything is OK.
Alright.
Should Alex try to open the safe?
Yes.
I have a confession.
I...OK.
I'm so bad with these types of locks.
So I had one when I was living in Japan.
And I couldn't ever get it open.
And I was too anxious to talk with the people running the building.
That I just never got my mail.
Like the entire time that I lived in Japan.
They taught me once and I was too afraid to ask them again.
And so...
I...
I just never checked my mail ever.
I hope there was nothing important in there.
I have to wait for a click, right?
OK, I can't hear the click over all this ambience.
Am I going to...OK, reset.
OK.
Oh, right, left, right.
So, right.
Nice and easy.
Clockwise first.
OK.
I was pressing...
OK, I get it.
Oh!
OK, but...the...but it's...
This makes no sense!
Actually, this makes more sense.
It makes sense in my brain, OK?
The other direction makes sense in my brain.
You have to understand.
Because this side, the numbers are going left.
But in the other way, the numbers are going to the right even though they are going downwards.
Does it make sense?
It makes sense to me.
Trying the D-pad.
Oh my gosh, my D-pad is...
I'm having to really push on this thing.
Oh my god, please.
Is that a click?
Oh my god.
Most of the kids in my high school left their locks preset for the first two numbers.
All I had to do was turn the dial lock enough...
Wow!
Snowy, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Oh my god, please.
We are already almost there.
Come on.
Hello?
We need that guy that picks locks.
We need a lock lawyer, whatever his name is.
I'm almost back at the beginning.
The lock picking lawyer, yeah.
The first to the right is supposed to be 59.
I don't know why it didn't clunk.
Let's try again.
59?
Let's try it.
Maybe I just didn't hear it.
I'm going to turn up the sound.
Do I need to go the other direction?
Yeah, let's try the other way.
It was the other way.
Alright.
This is a workout.
Oh my god.
I'm having to push really hard.
Please.
Next one.
One after.
This one.
Next one.
Oh my god.
It shouldn't be this difficult.
It shouldn't be.
It shouldn't be this hard.
Oh my god.
Please, we are already almost to 70.
OK, it's starting to get easier.
OK, now I go back the other direction, alright?
Oh my god.
But the right button is easier than the left button.
One more kaplunk.
Wow, there is a lot of stuff in here.
At the safe... Wait, is that a handle?
Is that for the observatory thing?
At the safe's door hinge... Wait.
As the safe's door hinges open, its contents are revealed.
Many important items left behind by Edward lie on the shelves inside.
Collect the items.
We have the essence of Chiturga.
We have a crankshaft.
Yeah, we got it.
Oh my gosh, we can finally do that puzzle.
We have a letter from Edward.
Her grandfather.
And we have a chapter page.
Ashes to ashes.
Oh dad.
What is going on?
This guy is just chilling here.
Arms crossed.
A dome of metal and fire.
And a torrent of souls along with it.
Young and vibrant.
What does that mean?
Far gone.
With this sacrifice of souls I make unto thee, great one.
The gate shall be ready to be opened.
And your freedom shall be at hand.
I don't like that.
Yes!
We did it.
Save the game.
Holy cow.
This guy sounds like Solidus.
Kind of, right?
This actually kind of sounds like Solidus.
I wouldn't be surprised...
It would be less surprising if it was a MGS1 cast.
Let's read our letter from Edward.
I'm gonna have a chicken nugget.
I believe I have slowed Augustus' plans, but not stopped them completely.
He will still try to bring his Ancient into this world.
You must continue what our ancestor Max has started.
You must gather the artifacts and call forth an Ancient to combat what Augustus brings into this world.
Of the artifacts there are four, but one of these is in the clutches of Pius himself.
They are the Black Heart of Manta Rock, the Claw of Chiturga, the Sigil of Xelototh, the Veil of Uliath.
Your skill in the arcane science will not be as strong as Pius' who has had two millennium to prepare his gate.
That's not very fair.
You will need all the remaining artifacts to match his power.
It all rests with you, my dear.
I wish you well in this desperate act.
I wish I had more guidance for you, but I am at my wits end.
And I feel I am running out of time.
Your loving grandfather, Edward.
Nom, nom, nom.
Oh, Seven Grandpa.
Well, we have the Essence of Chiturga.
Hold on.
Shush, shush, shush.
So we need... Oh, I'm sorry, we have the Claw.
Wasn't the Heart like in the library or something?
We have two of them.
We do?
Oh yeah, there it is.
We have the Heart.
Yeah, we got that one.
So we have two.
So we need one more which is probably behind this puzzle.
And then we gotta get the one from Pius Augustus.
Alright.
Are we ready to do Ashes to Ashes?
Just two more.
Oh wait.
Sorry, my bad.
Let's do it.
I like your solid 3.
Look at that scene.
It looks like...
It looks like the very first scene of MGS3.
Michael Edwards?
Grandpa, why didn't you leave Elephant Gun?
I know.
1991!
This is the most recent one that we have.
It's a firefighter.
Hot!
Ok
Oh no!
Get out of there!
Wait, what's that growling?
Oh no!
Nooooo!
The Diaper Chief?
Oh my God, it blew up.
Oh my God!
Uh oh.
Am I gonna be in a familiar area?
But this guy's gotta have good stamina.
He's a firefighter, right?
Also, was that Greg Eagles or...?
Oh my God.
He's so powerful.
Is anybody else alive?
Yeah, that's totally him.
No!
Patterson!
My buddies!
Oh my God!
Wait, that looks like the tower!
Ok Ok
You couldn't...
You...
This guy's not explaining anything.
What?
This is the... What's it called?
This is that guy, the inspector, right?
That guy sucked.
You want me to take this to Rhode Island?
We have the essence of...
And of the ruby effigy!
Hey, Roberto didn't suck.
He kinda did.
He kinda was bad.
We got the sapphire effigy!
Oh my God.
Already?
We got a fire axe and a flashlight.
Finish him!
Nice Nice...
Nice Nice.
Should I do that to my friends too?
They might get up.
I see something sparkling over there.
Is it a person?
We got a flashlight this time?
That's crazy!
Let's... Oh, I can't save here yet.
Ok.
My friends!
They look like...
They look like they are among us cosplayers.
My friends... Yeah, let's do it to my friends.
Hold on.
Nevermind.
Just some bones lying about.
Oh yeah, that guy is gonna get up.
Oh my goodness.
Are you gonna get up?
Or are you just gonna be a lazy bone?
That's why I couldn't save.
This is like the torch.
It's like one hit.
It's awesome.
Oh my God.
What the?
How did you survive?
How did you?
I got your head though.
Oh, he is a big guy.
That's why.
It's almost as good as the torch.
Oh my God.
Almost as good as the torch.
Cinnabar.
What is that?
Oh, that's a person I think.
Anyone else?
Nope, just my friends.
Now we can.
Alright.
Michael Edwards.
What is going on here?
A desiccated corpse lies sprawled on the temple floor dressed in desert combat fatigues.
A rifle, pistol, and a variety of ammunition lie about him.
The soldier appears to have gotten down fighting.
Should Mike collect the weapons?
An assault rifle!
Oh my God.
Ammunition!
A pistol!
Another pistol.
Grenades?
Tip about the rifle you are about to get.
If you stick to burst fire you can get the whole level using only that gun.
Which mode is that?
Wait, let's check.
The 3 one?
The rifle also fires grenades.
That's insane.
The objective individual combat weapon OICW is a Heckler & Koch G36 rifle mounted under a 20mm grenade cannon.
It is commonly assigned to special forces units.
This rifle uses a 30 round clip and is chambered for 5.56mm NATO ammunition.
Wow.
But I kind of like my axe too.
I'll equip it.
Here we go.
Oh...
Which mode was it?
I can't tell what modes these are.
That's the grenade.
That's regular.
Is that burst?
And then what is this?
It's the 3 bullets right?
OK.
That's what I thought.
Oh he took him down.
Don't go after me.
Oh he's summoning more.
Lame.
Oh I have to... He's the guy that I have to...
Get close buddy.
Get close.
Can I switch to your head?
I'm scared.
You think he'll leave?
I'm stuck.
I'm actually stuck.
This is not good.
This is not great.
It's the moth from your audio book.
Oh my gosh.
She went on a date with him.
They went to an observatory.
And I don't remember what happened.
The babies are after me.
I'm leaving.
Oh yeah we are... Wow this area is very familiar.
Yes indeed.
For these guys I'm not gonna really waste ammo.
I don't need to.
Cause I can just one shot them with this.
So much easier.
You know.
There's still more.
Come on over.
Yup.
And I get him.
We're screaming?
Don't worry.
I guess I could have gone to the trapper dimension and gotten more...
More sanity but...
Oh my gosh this area.
No please.
I don't wanna be back here.
Okay so we have two.
I'm just trying to explore everything through here.
We have two ladders.
Hurt me more.
Zombies.
And we have three ladders.
Okay let's go to the first one.
All the way back.
Yeah we do have a strong character.
Thank goodness right?
A guy who actually like runs.
Look at how much health he has.
A guy that runs and... Okay we don't have the tome yet so we can't...
Cast any...
God.
I'm trying to decide if I wanna just run around him or not.
You know what?
Let's go to another floor.
When do I get the tome of eternal darkness?
I never have I wanted the tome so much more than...
In these moments.
You know?
Get the little guys.
Get the big guy.
Whack, whack.
Get the bigger guy.
Oh my god.
Take him down.
Finish him.
Oh my god my sanity is so low.
Sanity goes so fast.
Alright.
Get that guy.
And this guy.
And what are we grabbing here?
What is this?
It's a stick!
An odd battered staff.
Butcher mental.
We got a staff.
Very cool.
Let's keep going.
Let's go to the next room.
I thought it was a wand.
You're a wizard.
Edward?
What's this guy's name?
Edwards.
Oh.
Looks like a scale replica of the area.
The model is made from clay and seems brittle.
Some of the buildings appear to have been coated with a reflective glaze.
Okay.
Puzzle.
So if I reflect...
The depression lies on the floor in front of the model.
Perhaps something may be placed there.
Like a staff?
No, nevermind.
Mix it.
Long staff made from hardwood.
One end of the staff is merely bare wood, indicating that something was once attached to the end.
I see.
Depression me.
No!
Okay, we have to go back to that other horrible room.
We have to go back to that horrible, horrible room.
Alright.
When do I get the tome?
It's just like Raiders, yeah.
It is.
We'll save in the second slot.
Just in case.
How much...oh wow.
I actually have a ton of ammo.
But it feels like such a waste.
Gosh, I'm in such a survival horror game mode.
Don't shoot unless absolutely necessary.
But maybe here is absolutely necessary.
I don't know!
What is this?
Grab it!
Situated on a waist-high plinth is a gold amulet.
It's mine!
No!
Oh my gosh, there are two of them.
Just go!
Oh my gosh, this camera angle is evil.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Just go!
Just whack!
Don't stop whacking!
Finish him!
Oh my gosh.
Holy!
Survive somehow.
I know I have to face that room eventually, but I hate those winged guys.
What is this?
Climb up?
OK.
Am I gonna hate this room?
I'm gonna hate every room.
Hey!
We told them to fix this!
And they didn't!
They didn't listen to us!
Listen!
This room steals our sanity even.
Where is my...oh here it is.
You are gonna summon a new guy, aren't you?
Oh that's a big guy.
It's a big guy you just summoned there.
Where are you going?
One!
We got one guys!
We got one!
Finish this guy.
And take down this guy.
Take him down.
Nice.
Isn't there a guy over here?
He is already dead.
I'm too good at the game.
Yeah, we got a decent chunk of sanity back, didn't we?
Yeah, nice.
And the...what's it called?
The gas in this room disappeared.
What do I do in here?
I take a nice little sit on the bench.
Oh, here we go.
When do I get the dang book?
Oh, what is that sound?
Oh, we can't get him yet.
Turn around!
Turn around, Edwards!
OK, let's go back to the scary, scary room.
There has to be something in there.
No tome, no magic.
Nothing on that end.
Our walls are bleeding just a little bit.
Alright, guys, let's be brave.
Let's be brave.
I had to leave for a second there.
The horrors are easy to kill by double tapping.
Burst shots into their head when they are open.
A lot less scary now that you have this rifle.
Everything is scary still though!
Well, it's more so me.
Thinking I'm gonna miss and, you know, like...
And wasting all my ammo.
I admit, my birthday was yesterday.
I turned 20.
Carlos!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Carlos.
Happy birthday!
We forgot to also check this amulet.
Let's see what this is.
Circular in shape with a series of jewels clustered around what appears to be a glass lens.
It has a fitting on one side as though it was once attached to something.
We got a staff!
Thanks, Minto!
Of course!
A long staff made from hard wood.
It is finished once clean and resplendent, is now dented and cracked.
It is topped with a gold amulet and set with a lens.
So this is definitely...
We don't even have... We can just probably run past this room again then, right?
Wait, what's this?
Nothing.
Just run past!
What's this?
We don't need to do anything there.
We just gotta go to the other room.
If you kill every enemy in this level with burst fire and don't miss, you'll have about 40 rounds left.
Okay.
How do you know all this, Red?
Is this your favorite game?
Ever?
Cause you know a lot, a lot.
Alright.
Wait, what do you mean I can't use it?
Use it right there.
Oh, okay.
We probably gotta get them all lined up, don't we?
Wait.
Can I...
Can I move this?
Classic indie puzzle.
Cause it only points... It doesn't point any other way.
Huh.
The music has stopped.
It's like the game is like, hey, you're too dumb.
Oh, it can go up!
I'm an idiot.
You're right.
Oh my gosh, for some reason I was thinking it just goes left and right.
Okay.
I'm burning it?
I'm setting it on fire?
Let's just open this thing.
A hidden compartment has been revealed.
The rear wall of the compartment is lined with polished metal forming a crude mirror.
Now this one.
Can I move it over?
My depth perception with this is actually really at its max.
I can't... What?
I'm actually so confused here.
Oh my god.
Please move!
Is this as high as it can go?
Okay.
And then...
I...
There we go!
Oh my goodness.
Second mirror!
Okay, now upwards and over.
Upwards... There we go!
Oh!
Alright.
Wait, that's not what opened.
That's where we came from.
What?
It just opened.
Oh, right here.
Okay.
Go down.
It's tome time!
Wait a second.
Yes, yes, just claim it!
Take the tome!
Nice.
Back to the spooky room.
The room where I refused to kill those two guys.
I like how we look so awesome with our soul rifle.
Alrighty.
It was... No.
It was this one.
Wait, what room was it?
Wait, what was this one again?
Oh no, this is where we got the staff.
Okay, just kidding.
This is where we got the staff.
Oh yeah, we do have magic!
I can just shield, can't I?
Wait, let's check...
Yeah, why don't I just shield?
And then I can kill them.
They're green.
Wait.
Shield is the same color.
Oops.
I guess red is fine because it's my health.
Spell.
Let's enchant.
Oh no.
Yeah, this protects HP.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My sanity could use a little bit of a boost.
But...
Enchanted rifle time.
Will I be able to use it though?
I'm scared.
Alright.
Alright, let's do it.
No!
Why did you die?
I'm trapped!
Can you lift up?
Can I get the other guy?
Can someone lift up?
Can someone do anything?
Oh my god.
Please.
No!
I give up!
I hate these guys.
I hate them so much.
I'm never dealing with them ever again.
If I see them ever again I'm running.
I don't care.
I don't care about anything.
I hate them.
I hate them so much.
I hate them!
This stupid fucking controller moves around too much for me to just focus on their head!
I'm going to go get tea.
I'm back.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Hold on.
Thanks for all the superchats!
Thank you!
Oh no, I didn't get some of the syrup off my fingers.
Sorry, did you have to listen to baby crying this whole time while I was gone?
I'm so sorry.
What was I doing?
Oh yeah, I was just paused.
Alright, to this room.
Yeah, it was awful.
I'm so sorry.
Oh yeah, let's regain our cover.
We'll do it at an extreme level.
Hey, go away!
It's not supposed to be drippy anymore.
My sanity is healed!
Please!
Alright, let's go down.
Let's dispel.
Why is it still drippy?
Okay.
Dispel magic, cast red, seven.
Oh, we had barely just enough.
Amayoshi, how many shiny days?
Emerald effigy.
Oh!
Gosh!
Are they dead?
I think they're dead.
I think we're good.
Please, I need to...there we go.
Why won't it stop being drippy?
Do I go down here?
No, we don't want to follow the worms.
You know what?
Good idea.
Let's just go.
Let's just get out of here.
What am I supposed to do with these things?
Was there any...
So now I have three effigies.
I'm supposed to put them somewhere, probably.
I'm trying to think of where I'm going to put them.
You guys, we all have a little bit of worm inside us, okay?
We all got a little bit of worms inside us, it's no big deal.
It's NBD, no big deal.
No biggie.
Is this the room that I hate the most?
I'm not even...okay, I'm going to use my trusty axe, you guys.
Oh, this isn't the room.
Not yet.
Do brain worms count?
Absolutely.
What the?
Where did the little guys come from?
Oh my gosh.
They're coming.
They're coming and I'm scared.
Remember your magic.
Heart.
I hate these guys.
Why do they have to give me two of them?
Gosh, it must require a lot of magical.
Cinema.
Wait, my magic is full.
Wait, what?
Wait, now it's all the way gone.
What?
He's not magical enough.
He's just a small magic guy.
Oh, so he's got like bigger sanity and other stats...
but he can't do level 7, some level 7 spells.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, no.
Mike, no!
Okay, alright.
I just have to run through, maybe.
But where do I go with this?
Okay, hold on.
What do I do with these?
A small statue of a scholar ravaged by an unseen foe is made...
Is that why he's on his knees?
No!
Scholar!
What about this one?
A small statuette of a sorcerer driven mad by an unseen force is made from a lustrous sapphire.
A small statuette of a defeated warrior kneeling in respect to an unseen victor is made from a deep red ruby.
You opened a way through the lights puzzle.
What was down there?
Oh, I'm really losing it, aren't I?
Okay, I'm just gonna run past these guys once again.
Why do they keep doing this to me?
Oh my gosh.
I like how the sim symbol is just getting stuck on the wall.
Wait.
Okay, it's not gone.
Okay.
Let's go back through here.
Climb down.
Oh, did I not go through here?
Am I stupid?
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, that's right.
I went down here.
And it turned into the tome.
That's why I completely forgot.
That's right, that's right.
I was like, wait a sec.
That's right.
Oh my gosh.
That's fine though, because we needed to go get the other effigy, so it's fine.
On your channel, when you started this playthrough, I had a blast watching you play and love this game.
Count me in as a new fan of yours.
Nevermore, thank you!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you so much, and thanks for sticking around.
Thanks for the superchat, I really appreciate it.
Welcome, welcome, yeah.
Oh gosh.
You've seen me at my best and my worst, eh?
Alright, let's go up.
Let's go down.
Let's cast.
I cast, enchant item cast.
Wait, I can do seven.
I cast on gun.
This item is now enchanted.
We don't have...
Our...
Oh, it didn't last very long.
That's okay, we should be fine.
I say.
Oh gosh.
That was so close.
This might be the best weapon in the game.
Wait, let's go finish this guy.
No, no.
Okay, let's finish him.
Give me the sanity boost, baby.
Nice, nice.
This room looks clean.
This room is like the cleanest room we've seen.
Why are all the lights on?
How is the fire burning?
Before we go down, I will save once again.
I am a save scummer in this game.
I cast gun.
Can't wait to see him give the book to grandpa.
Or not the book, but the thing to grandpa in Rhode Island.
Okay.
Who's here?
No room is safe in this game.
Camera angle, please.
Okay.
Maybe we're fine.
Ish.
I say fine.
Maybe we're fine.
Oh, there's a ladder here.
And there's a...
Let's also go down here.
Let's...
Oh, wow.
There's way more.
Okay, and there's another ladder over here.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go to the first one.
Let's check it out.
Get his face.
No, that's arm.
Reload.
Did that guy just fall down?
Oh my god, please.
There we go.
Alright.
He got tired.
He was like, I can't handle this anymore.
He's like, I literally can't.
Yeah, take that.
Take that.
And finish him.
Oh, no.
He's not done yet.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, no head.
No head.
Take that.
And finish...
Can I finish him yet?
Why are you so strong?
Oh, there we go.
Woo!
And yet the walls continue bleeding.
I love that there is friendly fire in this game.
It might be my favorite part.
Well, not when I shoot the maids on accident, but you know what I mean.
Angel, thank you for the gift.
Thank you so much.
We came up from there.
Is there... Is this a way?
No.
Okay, so we are going down.
We come up just to go down.
Holy cow.
Take that.
I can't see.
Can you?
Yeah.
Oh no, please.
Please, no, please.
Please, stay away from me.
Stay away from me, please.
Oh, he's right there.
Oh gosh, he's right there.
It's blue!
I got the wrong thing.
Oh my god.
Go away.
I cast run away.
Why is he still stealing green then?
If he is a blue guy.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna try the pistol.
I'm sorry.
I know... Actually no.
While this is enchanted, I should at least try.
Finish him!
Finish him, please.
Take him down.
I don't want to see his stupid nasty face anymore.
What about this guy?
He's over here whacking it by himself.
Hey guy.
You got no head.
He's like whacking his arms around you guys.
What did she mean by that?
What do you mean?
He's like...
You know?
Let's save since I just defeated that thing.
I'm gonna actually save over Roberto.
I'm sick of seeing his face.
Sick of seeing Roberto's face.
Oh my god.
Pistol time.
Isn't he gonna explode?
Don't explode.
And... you too.
Nice.
She hates Roberto.
If your name is Roberto and you are in the chat... I'm sorry.
Is this a door?
Anything can be a door if I...
If I knock hard enough.
Oh wait.
This is a door.
Is this not a door?
It must be a door later.
This is where... Oh my gosh.
I remember.
This is where we let our little skilly friend die.
Hi ghost lady.
Hi Squidward.
Squidward.
No head and whacking it by yourself.
Should I sue for my likeness?
Are you a zombie?
Gosh.
Don't get... Oh my god.
Don't get... Don't get... Don't get...
Don't get... Don't get surrounded now.
Don't get cornered.
Alright, now we can finish him.
Yeah!
Number one!
Number two!
Number three!
Number four!
Cinema.
Roberto was my name in Spanish class?
Were you one of those teachers that made you pick a name?
Oh big guy.
Big guy incoming.
He's like whoa, whoa, whoa.
Aww.
You don't like my axe?
I feel like the guy from... What's it called?
From Lord of the Rings.
And my axe.
Oh.
A strange obelisk made from a dark granite-like material.
It appears to be blocking the way forward, but the obelisk appears to be impervious to all damage.
A Gimli.
What one's that?
Spell.
So it was a triangle.
Wait, let me see my runes.
It was this one.
Do we gotta be a little trapper?
Can I go in there?
Can I fit?
Can the trapper fit in there?
Summon trapper.
I cast.
Bye!
Oh, goodbye.
RIP little guy, he did his job so well.
07 little guy, 07.
Okay, nice.
Well, let's go through this door first since I didn't check in here.
Let's find zomboes.
I can handle... oh, depth perception.
Okay.
Can I handle this actually?
I don't know.
Oh my god!
Finish him.
Oh, I could have finished him.
Damn.
I've never seen him hug me like that before.
Oh my gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
The music even changed.
What the?
There's a guy stuck in the ground?
He's gone.
It's fine.
Let's recover some sanity.
Sanity!
Actually, let's leave it down a little bit so we can see some funny things happen.
Who's this?
A warrior!
The image is very strong, dominating this part of the room.
Below the design, a small ledge protrudes from the wall as if awaiting...
Awaiting something such as a ruby effigy.
Oh, we are in so bad shape, guys.
We are in really bad shape.
Oh, please move.
Oh my god, please move.
We are in real bad shape.
Oh, okay, good.
Holy moly!
Okay, I get the babies.
I get the babies.
You guys, we have the babies again.
The babies are back!
Oh, let's... No!
Oopsie.
Do I Pokemon them here, maybe?
Because it didn't let me do that.
So let's Pokemon them here.
Red, he awaits...
Okay, this one is... Oh, the babies are gone.
This is a female scholar.
Her authoritative glare dominates this part of the room.
Below the design, a small ledge protrudes.
Okay.
Wow.
We are smart.
So green is...
Green is blue.
Yeah.
Oh, gosh.
For some reason my brain was really telling me otherwise.
But I was like, no, that's the case.
A sorcerer casting a spell.
There is an air of authority about him, conveyed by his dominating visage.
Below the design...
Hidden staircase!
Okay.
Wow.
Okay, we got a lot to explore real quick though.
We got a lot to explore first.
We've got the trapper area that we unlocked.
He looks so badass walking towards the door with a gun.
He looks so awesome.
How much... Oh, let's...
He is so cool.
Yeah, he is pretty cool.
So, back in this room.
But let's not go there just yet.
First, let's save.
Alright.
Down.
Down, down we go.
That sounded like...
Either a zombie or a trapper.
I wish it was an easier way to switch weapons.
So that I didn't have to always go into the menu.
It's my small complaint, you know.
It's my small complaint.
Oh my god, another staircase!
I remember, this is where we got that one effigy.
Right here, wasn't it?
Right there, hidden in the wall.
I think.
Or am I crazy?
Wasn't there a door here that led to like a crazy fight?
I don't know.
The statue stairs are missable.
Wait, seriously?
Oh, OK.
Let's go back then.
I thought those were how you progress.
Oh my gosh.
OK.
Just kidding.
We are going this way first.
Oh!
Any Michaels in the chat?
OK.
Does it stay enchanted?
This Gladius carries a powerful enchantment.
This unique weapon can only be wielded by its destined owner, the Guardian of Light.
One medal is full of Michaels.
So true.
We have plenty of Mike H's.
I'm seeing.
Pre-enchanted weapon?
Wait, why can't I use it?
I can't equip it for some reason.
Oh, I'm not the Guardian.
I'm not the Guardian of Light.
I'm not the destined hero.
I thought I was the main character.
I thought it was me.
No.
I thought I was the main character.
Alright, now let's save one more time before I continue onward since we got that.
I'll take that.
Bind!
I can bind things now.
You guys, that's it!
We've gotten every spell in the game!
We are a Tome of Eternal Darkness master!
A note is scribbled on the scroll.
It reads, this magic enables the caster to bind a creature with magic, forcing it to ally with them.
Huge.
Oh, I can't go up here.
Who do I make my friend?
Okay.
Can I use it from here?
Do I have to go through the...
Wait.
Let's new spell.
Wait, what was it?
Bankorok Aratak.
Bankorok.
Aratak.
Parkonparkonparkon.
Let's go!
Now for this spell, is it...
Maybe I should do the 5 star one too.
Just so I have it, just so I have it.
Bankorok.
Aratak.
Parkonparkon.
Bind, cast.
Oh yeah, we might not even be able to do the 7 point.
So, it would be red then, or is it green?
Because he's a green guy.
Or is it red because he's opposite of green?
Is it red?
I'm trusting Pokemon rules, okay?
Let's see, my friend.
Was it not strong enough?
Maybe.
Okay, hold on.
I have to run around and regain my...
It makes sense that it has to be 7.
I wasn't sure if we could even cast a 7, so...
It makes sense, it makes sense.
7.
Horror is a 7 point, so...
Alright, let's see.
Fight my friends!
Yeah!
Fight my friend!
You can win!
You can win this!
Yeah!
Take him down!
Kaiju fight real!
Oh my god, now I don't have to summon the kaiju anymore.
I can just possess him.
Oh, why did my guy have to die?
Why did I have to possess the weak one?
No!
Anyway...
Rest easy friend.
Not you.
You suck.
You possess the one with the inferior genes.
It always happens that way, doesn't it?
What's this?
A block of explosives?
Probably a leftover from the war.
C4!
C3?
C3!
C number.
Destroy this.
Wait, there is some ruins down here on the ground.
What was in this room?
I can't quite remember.
How do I get to this?
Why am I listening to the scary voice?
Why am I listening to that?
Destroy this.
What's this?
I don't remember how to get there.
We came through that door.
This door, for some reason, doesn't open.
What was... There is no door here.
Ok, this was the mantle room.
This seems to be a one-use explosive, so it's not like I can blow up another door to make way for the path.
Like that, you know.
Let's go back down here and see if there is anything else.
Remember Roberto's chapter?
Guys, that was so long ago.
I don't remember where it's at at all.
Yeah, this is...
We got something in that room, I do remember.
Oh, that's the door.
Aren't all explosives one-use?
You know what I mean.
We only have enough for one explosion, that's what I mean.
That's what I mean.
Multi-use explosive.
Pink.
Where?
Like, I remember being in that room and the worms.
And we had to lower the bridge.
I remember what we had to do in there.
I just don't remember how we got to there.
Now I just feel like I'm backtracking, but...
I mean, I am, but I can't tell when I've backtracked too far.
Too close to the sun.
Pink.
I don't think the map is going to be any use, but...
You must find the P floor.
Wasn't there a door in that room with the trapper plinth?
The P floor.
Where was the P floor?
You would think I would remember that.
Yeah, I know I have a map, but it doesn't really help.
Is it?
They all look the same.
I don't even know where I'm at right now.
That's where we just got the explosives, right?
And then...
If you can't find it, make it!
Definitely back in the room you summon the trapper.
I'll go back.
P floor.
Wait, where did I summon the trapper?
Let's just go back a little bit, guys.
Sorry, I'm so lost.
I'm feeling...oh wait!
Oh, ok.
That's where the worms...
We haven't gone...
Do we go down this way?
I'm so lost.
Oh, ok, ok.
Yes, we went down here and then we got the effigy from here with the worms.
And then we went this way.
And then there was an up here, but there was more.
There was also ups and stuff down here.
Do I go up this?
Oh, I found things in here.
Why am I so...why is this messing with me so much today?
Usually I'm pretty alright with remembering some of these places, but this is screwing with my mind!
Andrew!
Thank you for the raid!
Welcome back, master and lady!
Hello, my name is Mint.
I'm a...I'm a ghost made Vtuber.
I'm playing Eternal Darkness and I'm really lost right now.
So sorry, you're coming out of an awkward time.
Hello!
Thanks for the raid!
Ok.
I'm so lost.
Oh guys, I'm so lost!
Oh no!
I can't remember at all!
No!
Oh my gosh!
I have low sanity right now.
Back to the worm pit.
Up the wall ladder.
Down the...ok, hold on.
Rett is my GameFAQs right now.
Rett is my GameFAQs tutorial.
Thank you.
I'm so lost.
Guys, I'm so lost.
I feel so stupid right now.
Ok.
Worm pit!
Up the wall la...wait.
Worm pit.
Up the wall ladder.
Back down the hall.
Door to the broken zombie crusher.
Into the hall.
What?
Ok.
You're talking about the game.
Yeah.
I'm playing a game.
Ok, so zombie head crusher.
And we go...
Wrong parameter!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Door next to the zombie crusher.
End of the hall.
Oh my god!
An innocuous panel wall caps this end of the room.
It is conspicuously empty by comparison to the other walls of the room.
There was a...oh my gosh.
Silent Hill 2 moment.
There was a...there was a door here.
It's gone now.
Mix?
What do I mix the explosives with?
A gun.
Mix the explosives with...
The essence of...
Yeah.
What's the detonator?
Why can't I just shoot it?
What's the...
Damn.
What is the...
The detonator.
Shape it into a butterfly.
Do you know it?
Detonator?
I hardly know it.
Ok, well now...
C4 is tricky to explode.
I'm not even sure if shooting would work.
Really?
Why?
Ok, well now we are at another impasse.
Because I don't have the detonator.
Ok, what's that red thing in your inventory?
Red thing?
This?
My flashlight?
I don't have anything like a...I only have guns in my inventory.
Don't worry.
Which...I'm just gonna do the highest level.
If I do purple, will it do all of them?
Time to find out.
If only there was a spell that made it invisible.
I'm way ahead of you.
Oh, now I'm invisible.
I forgot that it does the opposite.
Oopsie.
Let me just get my magic back, you guys.
Ok, reveal invisible.
I don't know what level it needs to be.
It's not invisible.
I can clearly see it.
Right there!
How about that?
Oh my god.
Wow, I remember this room.
Detonator caps!
Receive some more plastic explosives!
Handle with care!
We have a detonator cap!
Oh my gosh.
Wait, what's going on here?
What?
I know.
Ok, here...
I just need the shield, right?
It's the shield for like...
Just in case.
It's the shield for...
Destroy this.
It's the shield for...Purple can work, right?
I guess.
Stop backseating, Elder God.
I know, he's so needy.
Like, chill out.
I'm almost there.
Shield.
Purple.
Run around, run around, run around, run around.
Wish I had some liquid courage right now, but... for my magic.
Maybe...ok, what if I did 5?
Do you think I'd still make it?
Time to see.
Time to see!
2, 3, 4, 5...
It worked.
Let's rock spells are cast at a premium over normal spells.
Oh, I'm pretty sure Michael is the only one who is too low to cast some.
Michael!
It's ok.
He's been good, so I'm not...ok.
We gotta destroy the worms, everybody.
Put down the C4...
Sorry, these cutscenes are taking me out.
They're so fast.
They're like...
Reload!
Destroy this.
The lever is gone now.
Can we still see these?
He doesn't even care.
He doesn't want to examine them at all.
He's like, what's this mumbo-jumbo?
Why is everybody talking about worms and shit?
I don't care about worms.
Mix with the detonator cab.
We've assembled a bomb!
Minto assembles a bomb on stream reel.
Detail.
For centuries, evil has been channeled through this pit.
Countless souls sacrificed to the darkness.
Someone must end this madness.
A bomb placed here would be enough to pull the already collapsing city down into oblivion.
Destroying everything inside.
Do we know that for sure?
I'm gonna save.
Is this gonna be timed?
Oh gosh, we have 3 minutes to get out.
We have 3 minutes to get out, you guys.
Even with all the explosives, there's probably not enough to bring down the city.
There must be some way of making it more powerful and increasing its damage potential.
How do I make a bomb explode-y harder?
No way.
Can I make a 7 point?
Bargain, bargain.
Magic bomb.
Mike has activated the bomb's timer.
The countdown has begun.
Almost an answer.
Oh wait, almost an answer.
A deep, low rumbling begins to reverberate through the dungeon.
Mike has 3 minutes to escape the forbidden city and get to save the- 3 minutes to detonation.
Oh shit.
Oh no, a shield.
No!
Oh my god.
Wait, wait, wait.
You guys, we're in trouble.
We're in trouble, we're in trouble, we're in trouble.
Is it like one of those- Is it like super giddy giddy like this type of- Why is it rumbly?
I know, like the guy said he's reacting.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, no, he's- No, please.
Oh, hello?
I equipped that.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Get out!
Just run.
Open the door.
Oh my god.
Wait, how do I get out?
Wait, oh my god.
Wait, oh gosh.
The doors are all different.
Little tinies.
They're so small.
Just run.
First thing you see.
It's a maze.
This is messed up.
Oh my god.
Wait, I know where- I know where we are, kind of.
We got the staff in there.
Oh my god.
Just run.
My health.
Is this a door to leave?
This looks like an exit.
I made it!
I think.
A few years later.
Oh my god.
Welcome to Rhode Island.
Hello?
Are you Michael?
But that's not the point.
What's this?
Something you need.
Don't open it here.
Only in privacy.
They can sense it if it's not shrouded.
Is it one of the artifacts?
You must leave now.
But there's something I have to do before they get to me.
I can't protect you if they find you.
He has to go to Alaska.
Good luck.
Gray Fox!
Oh my god.
We did it baby!
Chapter complete!
First try.
We gamed that last bit.
My chat is frozen once again.
YouTube is acting so silly to me.
She has the same reaction every time.
Hold on.
I'm trying to get my...
Trying to get my YouTube back to normal.
Sorry guys.
One second.
Alright.
So...
One more chapter?
After?
That one?
One last chapter?
Or was that it?
Her sanity.
I think we should...
I think we should recover some of that.
This game is so long.
I know.
And the worst...well not the worst, but the best part about it...
is they want you to play it three times!
They want you to play it three whole times baby!
Oh my god!
Holy cow.
Scared the heck out of me.
I didn't hear you at all.
Hey!
Stop finishing him please!
Yeah!
Take him down!
Oh, his head is still there.
Alright, all we got to do is get to the...
We just got to get to the...
That one room.
My house is overrun by zombies!
This sucks!
My house was the safest place in the game and now there are zombies.
It sucks.
OK.
It's this room down here.
The rest of the game is about as long as it took for Edward's chapter.
Really?
That's it?
So about two more hours?
We got this guys, we got this.
That's why I started early today.
OK.
Ghost complains about undead.
Look.
Alright.
We got this.
Oh.
Adjust the mirror?
Wait.
Can I use it though?
It won't let me put it in.
Hello?
There be dragons here.
There be dragoons here.
Oh, maybe here.
Why won't it let me put it in?
Maybe here?
Why won't it let me put it
in?
OK.
Let's do that.
Maybe I don't need to do that.
Oh, what did I just do?
Does it go down here?
Or does it go over here?
Maybe I don't need the crank like I thought I did.
OK.
And then...
And then this last one bit right here.
Aha!
What about the last artifact?
And...
What about the next chapter page?
I'm just gonna...
A
little busy!
What the hell?
Can you help me please?
I'm being attacked by zombies!
Can you enter my home and leave?
Wait!
Wait.
Not his problem.
Get
it.
Go.
Stupid.
Stupid skellies.
Also, whoever said undead, there is a way bigger difference between skellies and ghosts.
Ghosts are way superior than skellies.
A package wrapped in brown paper has been left inside the door.
I got a brown paper parcel!
What the hell?
A parcel wrapped in plain brown paper.
It is not addressed to anyone and appears to have been wrapped in a hurry.
There might be something inside.
That means we could leave at any time?
This guy was able to get inside our house so easily.
We don't lock the door?
Oh my gosh!
Where did this come from?
We got the essence!
The enchanted gladius!
We are the one!
One star rating.
Reason?
They delivered my package while I was being attacked by zombies and didn't send for help.
Seriously?
I also would like to rate them a one star because they walked inside my home.
Wait.
Can we...
Do we have?
Oh we do have it!
We have the power!
It's probably gonna be guys down here too so...
Or not.
There will be guys inside here.
Time to save.
Alex Roivas.
Try swinging it.
Rawr.
Oh my gosh.
Alex is here.
Wait.
What's this?
Oh that's the one in the water.
Is she gonna get her own cutscene with this?
Sorry I just spat all over my thing.
Oh.
Okay.
Guardians of Zealototh.
Nine great towers dwarf the surrounding buildings.
It would appear these towers serve some kind of focusing array, channeling great tides of energy into the city itself.
Couldn't even get a higher resolution city.
Are there any things here?
Oh well.
Oh my gosh.
The other guardians I guess would be around huh?
Oh even the camera angles are a bit different.
That's neat.
Because they said there were other colonies like guardian colonies or whatever.
Let me check my health.
Oh it's okay for now.
We were here a few hours ago.
We were!
Okay.
This is what you guys meant by the piss room!
I remember.
I had no idea what you guys were talking about.
That's what they did to this place after...
After we used the towers to destroy them.
Oh my goodness.
Spell list.
Dispel magic.
Hold on.
Oh it's a 7 spell.
Okay, dispel magic, cast...
Red!
What?
No!
What the hell!
Uh oh.
We're out of shield.
I don't think we can do this.
Oh shoot.
Okay.
Are we just gonna die then?
We have nowhere to go.
Everywhere is covered in piss.
Poor planning.
How was I supposed to know?
You can cast dispel magic from the entrance.
You're going to die now.
Oh.
It reaches that far?
Okay.
Rest in peace.
I think I saved right before we went inside the tunnel itself.
So we'll have to see.
The darkness comes!
Well I'm gonna stop the darkness from coming!
Death by piss.
Yeah, this is where I...
So we'll save right before we go inside.
I fought things twice here.
I fought some dogs, I fought some giant things, some giant guys.
There's so much that we fought, you guys, in our journey.
So much that we fought in the eternal darkness.
Once you saw the barrier, it should have 180.
I thought my shield would last.
Not gonna lie.
But also, it barely shows you the shield right there.
So it's like...
It's so silly.
So if I can dispel from here...
That was intense.
How's our magic looking?
I want to make it max.
I needed red.
Okay, now I need it really max.
Yeah, I just wanted to parg on more.
I wanted to hear... what's her name's...
What's her name?
The green one.
The one we're currently fighting.
I really like her.
She's so creepy, with like the whispers.
Zealototh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Spellist.
Shield.
Cast.
Red.
Oh, it is Jennifer Hale.
Oh my god.
Inside.
Wait, examine.
Oh.
These plants look like the ones Pius had encountered in the Forbidden City where he found the essences of the ancients.
Do I need to...
Put the essences there?
Do I have... I do have them, like...
Here.
Okay.
Maybe... this one.
Well, there's only two.
I would need...
What's this?
Part of the broken pedestal lies on top of the floor.
Pedestal fragment.
Oh, this would be the third one then.
Maybe it goes here.
We need another fragment.
Oh, here, here, here.
I found it.
Pick it up.
We got it.
Mix them together and what do you got?
And then we enchant it and fix it.
Spell it.
It's enchant, right?
Let me double check.
Yeah.
Cast.
I'll make it powerful.
It's been repaired.
Okay, now we put it back here.
Nice.
So now we put some ancient essences in there, right?
Use...
Does it matter which way I put them in?
But we still need the third one.
That's the one Pius has.
Okay.
I have manta rocks?
Oh I do.
You are right.
You are so right.
I was like I thought I had a third one.
The star gate is open.
Let's do this all...all over again.
So we are just doing the same thing again, right?
We are just spelling it?
Like before?
What are we fighting?
How do we beat it?
We have to...
They weren't kidding about the eternal part.
Read grandpa's last note.
That's right!
We are summoning!
We are summoning...
Oh my gosh.
So to get rid of green...
We must summon...
Wait, we must summon red.
So yeah, it's still...it's still chaturga.
Yes.
Fire beats grass.
What is the summon spell?
Would it be summon horror?
Tear and air attack.
The biggest summon.
Alright, let's go do it.
Let's go summon a friend.
Maybe a friend.
A friend.
Probably a friend.
We are summoning someone.
Someone that will help us.
Glad I got my little revolver.
It's very...it's very weird.
Like, I feel very...like when I do the chapters...
I feel very like I know what weapons exactly and everything that I have.
Oh, I don't think I hit that guy.
But when I'm Alex, I don't remember anything at all.
It's very strange.
Like I feel very out of my element.
I guess is the best way to put it.
Oh, the sword!
I forgot to try the sword.
Sorry, I remembered my...OK.
I forgot that it had something special going on with it.
Or not.
It's cool that Alex has weapons from previous heroes.
Oh,
it did...
Weird.
OK.
Summon...
Spell list.
Not summon.
Shield.
Cast.
And run!
Quick spelling the shield.
You know what?
That's probably smart.
I'll do it right now.
Even though I did that earlier and I completely forgot.
Oh wait, not cast a sign.
I forgot which one I did it to.
I'll do it under...
OK, up.
Number one.
The top one.
The top D-pad is it.
OK.
I'll try to remember, guys.
No promises, but I'll try to remember.
I'll try to remember.
I'm gonna go in a circle this time.
I'm gonna go from the far left and we'll go all the way around.
Guys, it's not focusing.
Guys, it's not...
It's not focusing for some reason.
It's not focusing on him.
It's not focusing.
For some reason it's not fo...
Oh my god.
I don't know why it wasn't focusing.
Weird.
Paragon.
I hope the next one is Paragon too.
Maybe it only works on the final boss.
I've never tried it on normal enemies.
I'm in town.
Is there a way to get around it?
Do I have to cast a spell?
What if I summon a bunch of zombies and I use them like a bridge.
And I just walk on top of them.
That would be so awesome.
Red invisible, that's what I was thinking was gonna be the reveal invisible.
I imagine all of these are gonna be like 7 point levels, so let's just try it.
Oh my god.
And then all of these levers, I don't have to do anything with them.
Awesome.
How's our magic looking?
Good?
What if we made the bridge?
Yeah, they made it so I don't have to pull the levers again, but I'm...
I'm wondering why the doors are working and why do they just go away then.
When I don't pull the lever, you know.
I want to pull the lever.
How bad is the final boss in this?
Am I gonna cry?
Am I gonna be really sad?
God, it looks so scary here now.
Summon.
We need Tear and Aratak.
Aratak.
There we go.
Creature.
Creature!
Let me save real quick.
Save before each room.
A lot easier with the Enchanted Gladius and the Mantarok rune.
Yeah!
I love having things.
Yeah, it doesn't focus on them.
It's okay.
I got a gun.
Reload!
I love having a gun.
Oh my god, shut up!
Shut up!
Shut up.
Peace and quiet.
This room is so smoky.
I don't quite remember it.
Oh, there's blood down there and everything.
Peace at last.
I know.
You just shoot everything for the peace.
Even the bars have blood on them.
Revolver Alex.
Six shots.
Enough to kill any trapper that moves.
Oh, this stays.
That's so good.
Thank goodness.
Oh my gosh, imagine if you had to use it every time.
Screams.
Any trapper that screams.
Running, running and running.
Running and running.
Alrighty.
How many left?
One, two...
Three, four, five, six.
Alright.
Well, five including this one, so six.
When in doubt, cast gun everybody.
I promise it works.
Paragon!
Do you think the next one will be Paragon?
I sure hope so.
Getting close.
We are, we're getting close.
Oh.
What?
This is the museum room.
It showed zombie, little trapper and then the big guy.
Can I not leave until I summon a friend?
Okay.
You couldn't... I just had a little cough.
I see.
I cannot leave.
Until I solve the puzzle.
Can I save in here?
Oh, I can.
Let's see what going on top of the big guy does.
Let's see what happens...
Here.
Attached to the monolith is a metal plaque marked with a symbol that looks like a silhouette of a horror.
That's not very nice.
Oh, I think I have to summon a green guy here.
Maybe.
But I can only do one summon at a time.
Belongs in a museum.
But maybe it will trap him.
Let's try it.
Summon horror.
Green.
There he is.
Here he goes.
He is back in the museum!
He belongs in a museum.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, next we do red zombie.
Maybe.
Summon zombie.
Red zombie.
I'm so glad.
There are these other monsters in here.
They look pretty gnarly.
I'm glad we never had to fight against them.
Okay, I'll go into my museum.
Museum.
Okay.
Get Indiana Jones dude.
Nice.
Alright, now we kind of have to run around a little bit before we summon our...
Before we summon our trapper.
Looks curiously like a trapper.
Getting my magic back.
We'll need more magic anyway for the shield.
Yeah, Alex recovers magic really fast.
She's kind of awesome.
I mean she's the guardian of light.
She's a badass.
Summon trapper.
I cast blue.
There we go.
That sound is triggering me.
The little...
Yippee!
We solved the puzzle.
We are so smart everybody.
Stay in there.
And stay in there!
Do you think I can make it with this shield?
Do you think I have to summon again?
I can't count how many I have left because I...
You can make it?
Nice.
Alright, next one.
Here we go.
Parkon, Parkon.
Oh my gosh, I hope it's Parkon.
Oh wait.
Let's reload our gun here.
I saw him.
I saw him with my ultra vision.
My night vision.
Parkon!
I'm ready to Parkon!
Interesting that there is mostly only little trappers here.
I say as I'm probably going to go into a crazy fight.
That's not what I expected.
Purple floor.
If I touch it, what happens?
Purple floor?
Save?
I can't.
What if it was purple?
Let's see.
I'm scared to go under.
Oh, maybe it's fine.
Just kidding.
Just kidding!
These cutscenes are so funny.
You can't Parkon.
Send someone to Parkon.
Now the floor is... Wait, did we get sent to the past?
Are we in the...
Let's see.
This is my favorite 2000s game.
Thanks for playing this.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Is it right?
I hope I'm saying it right.
Thank you!
Yeah, I did not get any info from that cutscene.
Wait, there is something flashing over there.
Let's see what it is.
Unless it's just fire.
It's just fire.
What do we have?
Reveal invisible?
Dispel magic?
Recover more sanity?
I don't think that will do it.
Shoot gut.
I remember being so confused because that looks like a pedestal where you put something.
I don't think this is a sanity effect.
This is a puzzle, but we just...
Every time a worm comes, I just shoot it.
So I don't know...
I don't know because I can't get out.
If it was a sanity effect, I would still be able to leave.
But every time a worm happens, I just shoot it.
So I don't really know how to deal here.
What do I do?
You might need to max your sanity again.
I'll try.
I don't know if this will be enough.
We are back where we started.
You need to walk...
I was going to try and figure it out.
You need to walk from the start of...
I was going to try and get it myself, but I don't think I would have guessed that.
I'm going to go really slow.
Usually the worm resets you if you run, so now I'm confused.
Let's see if it resets now.
Oh, he just takes all my sanity!
OK, well...
OK.
Walk without rhythm.
Sometimes let me try a little bit with the puzzles.
I really appreciate it, but let me...
I don't need an immediate answer always.
Let's see if we can... How slow is slow?
Oopsie.
OK,
here we go.
Here we go.
Don't notice me, worm.
My fingers are sweaty.
Here we go.
OK, here we go.
Oh.
I'm walking.
I'm walking here.
I'm walking...
Oh.
Can I...
Can I... If I get out of the purple, can I run?
I'm walking here.
Maybe it's okay now.
I'm out of the purple.
Okay, bye.
Nice.
I was walking.
Here we go.
Meow.
Okay.
Sneaking mission real.
Everything turns into a sneaking mission.
All the time.
I can't escape the sneaking mission.
How many of you wanna guess Paragon?
Type Paragon in the chat if you think it's Paragon.
Not Paragon.
Paragon.
Actually, what's the other one that we need?
Probably would be good to see what it is.
Summon horror...
We already did... Oh, we need Tear.
We did Aratak before.
It is...
Paragon!
Yippee!
Oh my gosh.
Why are we getting like a cutscene of these guys?
I see.
Oh, that's a little freaky.
I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Reveal invisible...
Were they blue?
Maybe I can do... Oh no, that would make me invisible.
Just blast the room?
Actually, you know what?
That might be a good way to do it.
It's damage field, right?
Let me check.
Mystical power...
Oh no, no.
Wait...
Magic...
No, no, no.
That's stupid.
I'm stupid.
Summon chopper...
Magical attack!
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just gonna cast it...
Big boy...
Purple.
I don't think that worked.
Maybe I have to reveal invisible.
Let's see.
What is it?
I don't know what color they were.
I didn't see.
But the room is blue.
So if the room is blue, let's try green.
I think...
I don't...
Think so...
Oh gosh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
They're like right on me.
What if they're right here?
Can I still shoot them?
No.
Oh, now they noticed me.
Now they're all... I triggered them.
Ah!
Maybe let's just try red.
Oh.
Did not one shot them.
I think I...
There we go.
And you... I'm just gonna get...
Take them all down.
Take them all out.
Oh my god, they're so annoying.
Oh my god, please.
Shut up.
Honestly, these guys are so easy to kill though.
So I don't mind that this entire place is just infested with trappers.
Honestly.
I'm like, you know what?
Yeah.
Let it just be them.
I don't... It doesn't need to be anybody else either.
Wait, how do I get out of here?
Was it the door around here?
I believe so, yeah.
Okay.
They're kind of like cicadas.
Me, me, me, me, me.
Me, me, me, me.
Could have been the wing guys.
I know, they actually...
This is just kind of...
It's only a little tedious.
But it's not difficult.
And I actually don't mind that there's more...
That they're more puzzle-like than combat.
I think that's more fun.
You know?
I gotta use my brains a little bit.
I'll save before the next room.
Tensai Ghost!
Pargon?
Pargon, pargon.
Alright guys, you wanna bet this time?
You wanna bet if it's pargon or not?
Tear or pargon?
Not pargon, not pargon.
Tear this time, alright.
Let's see!
It was pargon!
You guys all owe me!
12k on tear.
It was pargon!
All the non-pargon believers...
Out of the chat...
You owe me...
A funny dance.
Okay...
It's so ominous.
Is this like when I just destroyed it before?
Lost the bet.
Oh yeah, wait.
I wonder...
What's happening?
What's going on?
In front of me!
This works now though.
It only doesn't work on the trappers for some reason.
But it worked on this guy.
Okay...
It's Zelda, for real.
I thought about playing the new Zelda game.
Wait, let's do a little bit away.
Let's do a little bit away.
Why don't we get a cutscene for this one?
He didn't even get to finish emoting.
And we took him down.
So easy.
Alright, now water.
Alright, this one will probably be the toughest.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm ready!
Oh my gosh, this sword is awesome!
Yeah!
It's so pitch black on my phone, I don't even know what I'm seeing on my screen.
Maybe adjust your brightness.
I don't think I can turn the brightness up anymore.
Oh, maybe I can.
Brighter.
Wait, did I just not save it?
No, I did.
Oh, wait a second.
Is there something else?
And yet the barrier remains.
Did I do all that for nothing?
Do
I have to...
I wonder if purple would work like a purple spell.
But obviously I need to attack them.
So magical attack...
Cast...
Purple.
Destroy the whole place!
Bye bye.
We took down the whole building basically.
Alrighty, where are we?
We are in this room.
So we need to go up here.
Okay.
Alright guys, just a few more.
VTuber, use your ult!
Just a few more.
But I think like...
Three more?
Run!
Oh, they are color-coded now.
Do you see that?
Like blue and orange and green.
Oh, two more.
I don't think this one is Paragon, you guys.
I don't think this one is Paragon.
I'm using...
This is an educated guess.
This is my hypothesis.
My hypothesis is...
This is not Paragon.
But what if it is?
Believe.
Not Paragon.
Tear!
What if you put in the wrong spell?
Do you get like a dumb ending?
I forgot to save.
But maybe we are okay.
Oh, a huge stone block etched with...
Barrier?
Oh, sorry.
Bizarre etchings dominates the room.
Is it art?
A memorial?
A tomb of the original inhabitants?
Or a bastardized internment of its loathsome conquerors?
Another piss room.
Oh, you can't?
Okay, hold on.
Where is the exit?
Dispel magic!
Fire!
I heard some guys though.
Where are they?
You hear them, right?
Is this the exit?
Yeah!
Easy!
Alrighty.
Alrighty, here we go.
I'm just gonna...I think I'm just gonna run for it.
Wait, how many times did it get zapped?
Two times?
I should be fine.
If I'm speedy.
Speed!
Go!
Uh-oh.
Told you guys.
Have more faith in Minto.
Gosh, you guys.
Last Pargon!
The final Pargon, you guys!
The last one is Pargon.
Pargon!
Title drop!
Oh my god.
Who are we summoning?
Am I the...am I...
Just cause I don't want to go through that cutscene again.
Here we go!
You are your last gone, Mismade Channel.
I have to make one of them my friend.
I have to...which one is the strongest one?
Become my friend.
I don't think I get to choose, which is really stinky.
Yeah!
Fight!
Wait, he is already dead?
I think we chose the wrong one.
One more time!
Fight!
Yeah!
My guy is the strongest.
My guy is gonna get...
No!
He is gonna get his ass whipped.
It's okay, I killed him anyway.
Nice.
Is there anything over here?
Just checking.
Nope.
Real dead.
Really, really dead.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Oh wait.
Sorry Alex.
Making her super sleepy.
Okay.
Mint cannot aim.
What are you talking about?
Why are you being so mean to me?
Don't be rude.
What are you talking about?
I can't aim.
There is an Easter egg for Mount to Rock summon.
Really?
How do I see it?
Bad, that guy.
I'm benevolent.
Wait a second.
Isn't this the room I was just in?
Oh wait, the exit is on the other side.
I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
We made it.
And one last P floor hopefully.
Hopefully.
More P floor.
No!
One last.
Hopefully.
Hopefully this is it guys.
We are so close to the end.
Oh it's purple!
Here we go.
Wait.
Would you like to save?
Oh yeah.
I would like to save.
Thank you.
I'm going to save right there.
Here we go!
We are going to have to fight that guy.
Him!
You!
Pious!
M'lady.
Yeah.
You tell him Alex!
We never get to hear Alex talk.
So it's kind of awesome.
Go Alex!
Go!
I'm the guardian of light.
Uh oh.
Wait, where is my summon?
I did one too.
Where is my...
No!
He's fart hunting!
Miss Zealotas!
Oh my god.
Dance for us!
Wowee!
There's mine!
My summon!
Wood.
He's yawning.
He's sleeping.
Wake up!
It's time to fight a lady.
Why is it so quiet all of a sudden?
Oh, you got a shield?
I can shield too.
Uh oh.
Wait.
Yeah, dummy.
What the?
Oh no!
I have to go dispel your thing.
Yeah, I have to go dispel your thing.
Hold on.
Let me...
Let me up there.
Oh shoot.
Do I have to reveal it first?
Reveal invisible!
Wait.
It was a 5, wasn't it?
Wait, it disappeared.
Just attack it?
Oh my gosh.
Hey, come here.
I see it.
The tome!
Oh my god.
My...
Oh, I see it.
Oh shoot.
Maybe I should have...
Oh my gosh.
Pooled.
Ah!
Oh my god.
They are all coming here.
Oh my god!
What the?
What is going on?
Pick up the tome.
I'm her!
What?
Wait, I don't have the cool sword anymore.
I don't have my good sword anymore.
I'm Alex again?
Uh oh.
It's taking a lot out of me.
Do I have enough time?
Quick 3 point magic pool?
I think it might be best just to recover some.
Ah!
Uh oh.
It didn't work you guys.
We messed up.
We are too slow now.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
He is so fast.
You told us of your disability.
What is happening?
What is going on?
It's here.
It worked!
Oh my gosh.
I need more.
Oh my god.
Run Alex!
I'm Alex again?
Oh my god.
Run.
Where are Anthony?
It's all the way up there.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go.
Stop being so tired please.
I know you are tired.
Me too.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh wait.
You don't attack him.
Dang it.
Oh I missed my chance.
Oh shoot.
Ouch.
What the...
Wait.
OK.
It's up here.
We are just casually walking.
Let me get a hidden.
It must be down here.
The simp.
Where is the simp?
Celebrating Christmas.
Back
to the kaiju fight!
OK.
Oh my god!
Maximillian!
Go, go, go, go, go.
Go Maximillian, go.
That's Maximillian!
Go Maximillian!
That's my great great grandpa!
Oh no.
It's OK, it's OK.
I know you are...
You are so weak right now.
Oh my gosh.
We are just running back and forth.
Just running back and forth.
There it is.
Run, run, run.
Oh my gosh.
I think we can kill him now.
Yeah!
Uh oh.
Did I summon the worst guy?
Nevermind, he is good.
Yeah.
He is sucking her up.
Oh my gosh.
Now it's a...
I don't know...
Will we even have time?
To be able to do all of this?
You don't need a spell just...
Oh, I thought it was... OK.
That was close.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Holy shit.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Oh no, no, no, no.
This is bad, this is bad, this is bad.
This is so bad, this is so bad.
Get eaten, Zealotath.
Wait, what?
We did it?
No way.
Oh my god, the clutch.
We clutched it so...
Yeah!
Oh my god, I really thought we were gonna die there.
That was crazy.
Great job, man.
Thank you so much for all your help, Riot.
I really appreciate it.
The wars.
But we saved Earth.
OK.
Bind.
I know that one by heart.
Grandpa, can I get a hint?
Grandpa.
I got the bark on Poki's neck.
I know.
Bind, bind.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom real quick.
Is this a timed event or...
No,
I actually do have to pee.
I do.
I have to go to the little ghosties room.
Pious, your attention is impious, you are par gone.
Guys, I'll never get this.
I'll never get this right.
I need help.
Phone a friend!
You guys, there are so many options.
Maybe...
What did I wake up to?
I'm looking it up.
Bind.
Eternal darkness.
Everybody knows that kids all look this up on GameFAQs when they were a kid.
Protect?
Thanks Rett!
What if I was wrong?
Wait, I'm actually curious.
What if he had been like...
No, no, no.
You dummy.
You stupid head.
Stupid dummy.
You got dookie for brains?
That's what he would have said to me.
Oh, really?
It is?
For now.
Grandpa.
Grandpa!
Bye Grandpa.
No!
She didn't even get to say anything to him.
Oh!
Thanks, I guess.
I think that once I could not see beyond the veil of reality.
To see those who dwell behind.
I was once a fool.
The end.
Dot, dot, dot, question mark?
Yay!
We beat it!
You've overcome the darkness!
That has prevailed for over two millennia.
This accomplishment will begin a new era for humanity.
Now, would you like to record this grand occasion in the pages of human history?
Yes, I would like to save.
Yeah.
In memory of Ben.
1920.
Is that it?
Oh my gosh!
Wait, is it his dad's?
The producer and director's dad?
One out of three done.
Oh my goodness.
This game is one of my nostalgic favorites.
Thank you for playing it.
To the end, and congrats on warding off the eternal darkness.
Copyright Silicon Nights 2001.
Yay!
We pargoned!
Oh my gosh.
I would always see this game at the game store and everything.
And I'd be like, it looks so scary.
And...
I'm finally glad that I could satiate my curiosity about it.
It's so awesome!
It's such a great game.
Now, two more times for the true ending.
How about...
No.
And how about we watch the true ending in a YouTube video?
Oh wow.
That's the mint way.
No.
I still really want to see the true end though.
But this is a YouTube video.
This is a YouTube livestream.
What do you mean you don't want to be Roberto again?
I feel like... I feel like though...
Well, actually, I don't know.
Towards the end, when you get all the different kinds of spells and everything, you...
Chris Zimmerman!
Voice talent director, yeah!
Chris Zimmerman, yeah!
That's the GOAT right there.
She's so awesome.
Oh, Gaglord!
I'm obsessed with taking more Rotopix.
I used to take Rotopix.
They're so fun.
Greg Eagles!
Richard Doyle, yeah!
Paul Eiding!
The three legends in one picture!
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
David Hayter, Jennifer Hale, and Paul Eiding in the same slide.
They knew.
Chris Zimmerman, for those who don't know, Chris Zimmerman is the voice director for Metal Gear Solid too.
Metal Gear Solid also.
If she's on the team, I feel full confident that the voice, the acting will be incredible.
Have you played Cold Fear?
I have not.
This game was so awesome.
It took, it definitely, it definitely can be a little, I don't want to say obtuse, but it can be quite a bit sometimes.
But...
It's...
It is...
Really, how do I say?
It's...
It is, don't worry.
Maybe obtuse is the right word.
I was going to say earlier, before I saw Chris Zimmerman.
I was going to say, I feel like I could probably beat it way faster now.
But then, you know, thinking about it, towards the end you get all the spells.
You feel so, like, you can do so much so quickly.
So, I don't know.
It's hard to say.
But also I wouldn't run around like a little chicken with my head cut off.
But it's such a good game, such a unique game.
So, oh my gosh.
So unique.
So creative, yeah.
You're OP when you know the spells, yeah.
Especially, you know, obviously thank you guys for helping me get Mantarok and the special...
The special sword as well.
Spell Royvus backwards.
Hold on.
S...
A...
V...
I'm looking at your tweet.
Sav...
Savoir.
Savoir, how fancy.
Coldfear is pretty good.
It's on PC, I highly recommend it.
Oh, check it out, thank you.
Neil Ross is in the game too.
I don't expect people to recognize him, but he was Sergeant Kelly in Doom 3.
And the Mayor of Midgar in Final Fantasy VII Remake.
Savoir.
Oh, Savio...
I was like, okay French, pop off.
Savior.
Oh gosh, how do I get out of the screen?
Thank you Nintendo, I get it.
Oh.
That's right guys, we are doing an endurance.
The other two endings, non-stop streams until we get the true ending.
This can't be happening.
Yeah, sanity effect me, completing the game.
With the other two endings in one go.
Mal de Savoir.
So when I play a new game plus...
Is that what I would have to play?
Well, I say new game plus, but...
So if I start a game...
Oh, you have previously completed Eternal Darkness Sanity's Requiem with the following alignments.
Zolototh, would you like to carry this information over...
Ah, so that's how it works.
Oh.
Oopsie.
No.
No!
Oh my God, Grandpa!
Hold on, I'm just going to turn off my...
I'm just going to turn off my GameCube.
Turn off the game console right now.
Okay, I've turned it off.
Let's check out... Hold on, let me...
Get my monitor.
Ready.
HDMI no signal.
Let's check out the true end and then I'm going to go eat dinner.
Because I'm hungry.
Bring us back to the maid cafe mint?
Okay!
Give me a second.
Oh.
I need both arms.
There we go.
It looks like I have like a par-gone beard now.
You guys like my par-gone beard?
Here, I'm going to make it a little bit bigger.
There we go.
That looks better.
That was better.
I'm so hyped for 3.0.
Me too!
Paius had two millennia of prep time and still lost.
They were like... I guess they said quickly, but I guess quick in like...
You know...
Celestial horror is like...
Way...
Longer, probably or something, you know?
Alright, true end, eternal darkness.
Let's check it out.
So, I'm guessing it's the special end?
Oh wait, true ending, Mantarok.
No, no.
Wait, Mantarok.
Wait, there's so many here.
Is this the special ending?
Is that what it is?
One second, let me see if there's any talking in these.
Oh, is it the epilogue?
Is that what it is?
The darkness vanquished epilogue?
True end, Mantarok.
Wait, I don't know which one to look at.
I don't know which one to check out.
Now I'm confused.
It's purple.
What?
No, it's not what I...
This one has...
This one has a final boss plus true end.
Let me see.
Okay, no one's talking in it.
Let's see.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so let's just do this one.
Give me a second, let me set it up.
Here.
This is from Torvus Channel.
Thank you very much, Torvus, for...
for uploading this.
Oh my god.
I can't get this right.
Okay.
Okay, sorry for the bad crop.
There we go.
Okay.
It's worth checking out some cutscenes of the other routes at some point too, Pius.
It's pretty different interactions with all three gods.
Yeah, I was thinking that.
I was like, wait, I want to know what Pius...
Like, how the other gods are and stuff, so...
Not today, obviously, but I'll check it out.
Goodbye.
Oh, there you go.
Now you can hear it.
I can stretch.
Purple.
Title drop.
Oh, I can see their mouths.
It's so dark, I can barely see anything.
Chaturga!
We saw that!
We didn't see that.
Cover it with my mouth.
My mouth.
Goodbye, Chaturga.
Mantorok in the cave.
I love Mantorok.
He's so chill.
He's just chilling down there in the ruins.
No!
No, don't die, Mantorok!
Warden of Ancients.
Chaos, an entity trapped between the veils of reality.
And the enchanted stakes that impale its flesh.
Look at his face.
Unable to rally its guardians.
It could rely only on its subtle manipulations...
Big ol' googly eyes right here.
...to destroy its enemies.
Knowing the nature of the Ancients, it used its pawns to play them against each other.
Resulting in their mutual annihilation.
Now, it will languish forever.
Vestring in its tomb.
Plotting.
I feel like...OK, now it just says that.
You've overcome the darkness.
I feel like that really opens up for an Eternal Darkness 2, does it not?
A sequel bait.
Yeah, that really opened it up.
Interesting.
Plotting.
Plotting, plotting, plotting.
Okey-dokey.
One second.
Let's put on some music real quick.
And then I'm gonna...
Yay!
Always wanted to play the game, but never got the chance.
Glad I got to experience it with you in chat.
Great job, Minto!
Thank you!
Too bad that...yeah, I guess there will never be...
...a second game.
I mean, Silicon Knights is not around anymore.
Unless there was like a...
...successor, I don't know.
Thanks for the stream!
Thank you!
Kind of a bummer, right?
Yeah, it is good on its own.
Can you imagine, though, what kind of...
Actually...
I don't know, I feel like...
...the sanity effects, some of them would probably look cheesy.
Like, old games like that...
You know, especially when you're playing it on a CRT or something.
You're playing it on a...
Nowadays we have such good monitors and screens and stuff that...
...things are too crisp.
But on an old TV, especially some of the sanity effects...
...like when the flies were on the screen and stuff like that...
...it looked so good, you know?
Especially if I were playing it on a worse TV...
...it would look really realistic and stuff.
So...
I can imagine...
Did you see the sanity effect that erases your memory card?
Wait, does it actually?
Does it actually erase your memory card?
Because no, I did not.
It does?
Oh, it pretends to.
Yeah, there's a lot of sanity effects that I guess I didn't get.
Because especially in the beginning I was so...
...nervous, I was like, I can't have my sanity go down.
I was too scared of...
I was too scared.
I kind of regret it.
I kind of regret it, because...
This is definitely a game... You know what, the fact that they have the multiple playthroughs...
...is good, because then it gives you more chances to see.
It's kind of a game that needs multiple playthroughs, so...
The fact that it encourages...
Firstly, you can have the multiple playthroughs just so you can play through it again...
...but also to further the storyline.
So it's actually...
It's actually kind of genius.
There's a few videos with all the sanity effects.
Oh, I'll check it out then.
What an awesome game.
So cool.
Too bad Silicon Knights is gone.
Rip, Twin Snakes.
Rip, Eternal Darkness.
What else have they done?
Silicon...
Knights?
Oh, not a lot.
I actually don't know.
Too Human?
I feel like I've heard of that one before.
But the other ones?
Oh my gosh.
I don't know them at all.
Their last game was in 2011.
Actually, yeah.
I think I've heard of Too Human before, but I've never played it.
The game that bankrupted them.
Now I'm gonna go watch some sort of video essay about it.
I'm gonna go watch a video essay about why Too Human is so bad.
But at least we got the Twin Snakes.
Despite what people say, I love it.
Alrighty, guys.
I am going to head off.
I'm going to go eat.
Thank you guys for going on this adventure with me.
It was a lot of fun.
I'm glad we could finally beat it.
And on to other games from here on.
So very cool.
Very, very cool.
Yeah.
Otsu...Minta?
Otsupargon?
And I'll see you guys next time.
I'm not streaming tomorrow, so I'll see you guys when I see you.
Bye-bye!
Thank you for the pic!
Lots of good mental gaming moments.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Bye-bye, everyone.
See you, see you, see you.
Thank you so much for watching.
Thanks for being here.
I really, really appreciate it.
Especially through all five parts of this insanity.
Thank you!
Okay!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!